GOOD MORNING. WELCOME TO THIS
SELECT COMMITTEE HEARING OF THE
CAREER TECHNOLOGY AND NEW
ECONOMY SELECT COMMITTEE. WE'RE
CONVENED THIS MORNING TO TALK
ABOUT SENATE BILL 755 AND THE
FINDINGS OF THE REPORT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PREPARED, SHARED
AND RELEASED ON MARCH 13TH,
2024. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
MEASUREMENT. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
DATA POINTS. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HOW WE IMPROVE DATA COLLECTION
AND PUT THE DATA TOGETHER TO
IMPROVE WHAT WE DO IN TERMS OF
OUR WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAMS
AND THE CONNECTIVITY BETWEEN
THOSE PROGRAMS AND JOBS THAT
ACTUALLY EXIST. YOU KNOW, I'VE
BEEN THINKING ABOUT THIS ISSUE
FOR A LONG TIME WHEN I FIRST
CAME TO THIS CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE, ABOUT 12 YEARS AGO, FOR
SOME REASON, I WAS TAKING A LOOK
AT ONE OF THE LOCAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD PUBLICATIONS
THAT HAPPENED TO BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO ME, AND I WAS
LOOKING AT IT TO REVIEW
STATISTICS ON TRAINING PROGRAMS
AND JOB PLACEMENTS, SPECIFICALLY
TO SEE IF WE WERE ACTUALLY
TRAINING PEOPLE FOR THE JOBS
THAT ACTUALLY EXIST. AND IF
PEOPLE TRAINED, WERE THEY
SECURING JOBS IN THE FIELDS AND
OCCUPATIONS FOR WHICH THEY HAD
BEEN TRAINED, OF COURSE, YOU
KNOW WHAT I FOUND IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE, I DIDN'T FIND
MUCH OF ANYTHING IN THAT
PARTICULAR REPORT. AND I
WONDERED, I WONDERED WHY I
WONDERED IF IT WAS SPECIFIC TO
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
REPORT IN QUESTION, THAT I WAS
LOOKING AT. BUT IF NOT, I
WONDERED HOW, AS A STATE, WE
WERE ACTUALLY ABLE TO MANAGE THE
MONEY THAT FLOWS FLOAD AND
CONTINUES TO FLOW THROUGH THE
STATE, FEDERAL AND FEDERAL AND
STATE MONEY IN SOME CASES MAY BE
WELL OVER $1 BILLION OR MORE.
EVERY YEAR, IF WE DON'T HAVE THE
DATA NECESSARY, NECESSARY TO
ACTUALLY ELIMINATE DUPLICATION
IN PROGRAMS, ACHIEVE EFFICIENCY
AND DEAL WITH THOSE TRAINING
PROGRAMS, IT SIMPLY DO NOT, WORK
. SO I THOUGHT, WELL, I'D LIKE
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT THAT. IT
WAS A LITTLE DIFFICULT TO GET
TRACTION AT FIRST. WE WERE I WAS
SORT OF BUSY. MY TEAM WAS SORT
OF BUSY. OTHER PEOPLE WERE BUSY,
AND THEN WE HAD THE PANDEMIC,
WHICH OF COURSE EMPHASIZED, I
THINK, TO ALL OF YOU AND
CERTAINLY TO US, THE IMPORTANCE
OF HAVING MORE AND BETTER DATA
ABOUT OUR WORKFORCE. YOU KNOW,
THE BENEFITS SEEM PRETTY CLEAR
TO ME. YOU KNOW, MORE
INFORMATION ON THE WORKFORCE BY
OCCUPATION INSTEAD OF THE
GENERAL INDUSTRY RELATED DATA
THAT WE HAVE SEEM TO HAVE TODAY,
WHICH DOESN'T ALLOW US TO DIG
DOWN AND FIND OUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN PARTICULAR
OCCUPATIONS, DATA TO ANALYZE,
THE QUESTION PRETTY CENTRAL
QUESTION IS OUR WORKFORCE TODAY
FULL TIME OR PART TIME? AND OUR
WORKERS EMPLOYED IN CAREER TRACK
POSITIONS WHERE THEY CAN
ACTUALLY HAVE UPWARD MOBILITY
AND SECURE HIGHER AND BETTER
WAGES, AND, OF COURSE, DATA TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE THAT STARTED
ME DOWN THIS PATH 12 YEARS AGO.
HOW EFFECTIVE ARE OUR TRAINING
PROGRAMS AND OUR TRAINING
PROVIDERS IN DELIVERING JOBS AND
SKILL TRAINING, SKILLS TRAINING
THAT ARE ALIGNED WITH THE
INTENDED OCCUPATION OWNS, YOU
KNOW, DO JOBS ACTUALLY EXIST IN
SUFFICIENT, SUFFICIENT NUMBERS,
FOR THOSE PEOPLE THAT WE ARE
ACTUALLY TRAINING AND I DON'T
KNOW THAT WE KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THAT, MAYBE WE'LL LEARN TODAY
FROM THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE GOING
TO COME UP AND, AND TALK TO US.
BUT AS I SAID, TRACTION WAS
DIFFICULT IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
GET A HANDLE ON THIS AND TRY TO
PUT A FIX FORWARD. BUT
FORTUNATELY, IN 2022, WITH THE
HELP OF A VERY, VERY, VERY
TALENTED ALLEGED CONSULTANT,
DOWN ROUNDS, DAN ROUNDS TO MY
LEFT AND MY STAFF SPECIFICALLY,
INCLUDING MY CHIEF OF STAFF,
GILBERT MARTINEZ, AND MY
PRINCIPAL CONSULTANT, KEARNEY
KING. TO MY RIGHT, THE
LEGISLATURE, WE PUT FORWARD IN
THE LEGISLATURE ACTUALLY PASSED
SENATE BILL 755, A BILL WHICH
DIRECTED THE EDD AND THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT OR BOARD, RATHER TO
DEVELOP A PLAN TO IMPLEMENT NEW
PROGRAM PERFORMANCE AND PROGRAM
EVALUATION METHODS FOR JOB
TRAINING SERVICES, SPECIFICALLY
ESTABLISHING THREE NEW OUTCOME
MEASURES RELATED TO HOW
INDIVIDUALS WHO RECEIVED JOB
TRAINING DO OR DO NOT SUCCEED IN
THE LABOR MARKET. TRAINING
RELATED JOB PLACEMENT, JOB
PLACEMENT AT OR ABOVE A REGIONAL
LIVING WAGE, AND UPWARD MOBILITY
OVER TIME THROUGH THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT'S BASE
WAGE FILE, NEW DATA POINTS WILL
NEED TO BE COLLECTED ABOUT
WORKERS AND THEIR EMPLOYERS,
SPECIFICALLY, OCCUPATIONAL CODE
DATA, HOURS, WORK DATA, AND
LOCATION OF EMPLOYMENT. AS THE
REPORT ILLUSTRATES. AND WE'RE
GOING TO GO OVER THAT SOME OF
THIS CLEARLY THEY'RE GOING TO BE
CHALLENGES IN IMPLEMENTING SB
755. AND THE MANDATE THAT THAT
IS CONTEMPLATED IN THAT BILL.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE SYSTEM
CHALLENGES. THEY'RE GOING TO BE
BUDGET CHALLENGES. THEY'RE GOING
TO BE CHALLENGES TO THE EMPLOYER
COMMUNITY IN A VARIETY OF WAYS,
BOTH IN TERMS OF SYSTEMS,
EDUCATION, INFORMATION, OAN AND
THE LIKE. HOWEVER, IN LOOKING AT
THE REPORT, FRANKLY, NONE OF
THESE SEEM INSURMOUNTABLE TO ME.
WHETHER IT'S THE BUDGET ISSUE OR
THE TRAINING REQUIREMENTS OR THE
SYSTEM UPGRADES. AND IT SEEMS TO
ME AS WELL THAT THE BENEFIT TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CERTAINLY OUTWEIGHS THE EFFORT
THAT IT WILL TAKE TO GET THERE.
SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ABOUT
TODAY. WE HAVE TWO PANELS. THE
FIRST PANEL INCLUDES
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY, THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT, AND THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD. THIS PANEL, NUMBER ONE,
WILL DISCUSS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S REPORT, THEIR
CURRENT WORKFORCE PROGRAMS, HOW
THEY USE THE DATA THEY ARE
CURRENTLY COLLECTING, AND HOW
IMPROVED AND AUGMENTED DATA
COLLECTION IS PROPOSED BY
SENATE. BILL 755 WILL FACILITATE
ADDITIONAL ANALYSIS OF WORKFORCE
PROGRAM OUTCOMES, PROGRAM
EVALUATION FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
RECEIVE JOB TRAINING. I THINK
I'VE SAID IT, BUT I'LL SAY IT
AGAIN, GIVEN THE CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENT BUDGET DEFICIT, IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT IT'S IMPERATIVE WE
FOCUS ON OUR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT INVESTMENTS AND THAT
WE MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
INVESTMENTS ARE DIRECTED TOWARD
PROGRAMS THAT WORK. OUR SECOND
PANEL CONSISTS OF SCHOLARS AND
RESEARCHERS FROM UCLA, UC
BERKELEY, AND THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA, AND THE
PANEL WILL PROVIDE TESTIMONY ON
THE VALUE OF COLLECTING AND
ANALYZING DATA USING THE BASE
WAGE FILE. THAT'S ENOUGH OF ME
TALKING. WHY DON'T I INVITE OUR
FIRST PANEL UP IN THE WELL TO
THE TABLE TO START THE
PRESENTATION? THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. AND I'M GOING TO ASK
YOU, ONCE YOU'RE SEATED TO,
INTRODUCE YOURSELVES, STARTING
TO MY LEFT. YOUR RIGHT THERE IS
AT LEAST ONE NAME IN HERE THAT
I'M SURE THAT I WILL NOT GET
RIGHT. AND I DO NOT LIKE TO
MISPRONOUNCE NAMES.
SO WHY DON'T WE START TO. OKAY.
YES, MA'AM. GOOD MORNING.
JENNIFER STURDY WITH, DEPUTY
SECRETARY OF EVALUATION WITH THE
LABOR AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY. THANK YOU, MISS STURDY.
IS IT WORKING? DOESN'T LOOK
GOOD, I CAN'T. THERE WE GO. GOOD
MORNING, SENATOR ROTH, MY NAME
IS JAVIER ROMERO. I'M THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE EDD WORKFORCE
SERVICES BRANCH. DIRECTOR
ROMERO, THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US, SIR. IS YOURS WORKING? YEAH.
GOOD MORNING, PADMAKUMAR
GOVINDANKUTTY, INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY MANAGER, WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD. AND YOU ARE A
PK. THAT'S A SHORT FORM. YEAH.
THANK YOU. THAT WILL HELP. THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US. YES, SIR.
GOOD MORNING. RANDY. JANICE WITH
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT, TAX BRANCH TAX
SUPPORT DIVISION. OKAY. WHO
WANTS TO START? I'M GOING TO
KICK US OFF. GOOD MORNING CHAIR.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING US TO
PRESENT TO THE COMMITTEE TODAY,
WE HAVE THREE OBJECTIVES FOR
THIS PANEL. THE FIRST IS TO
PROVIDE A COMPREHENSIVE OVERVIEW
OF CURRENT WORKFORCE PROGRAM
PERFORMANCE REPORTING AND
EVALUATION EFFORTS FOR THE
PROGRAMS DEFINED IN SB 755. I'LL
INVITE JAVIER ROMERO TO PRESENT
FOR EDS WIOA TITLE ONE PROGRAMS
AND PADMAKUMAR GOVINDANKUTTY
WILL PRESENT THE OVERVIEW OF
QUBE'S PROGRAMS AND THE CROSS
DEPARTMENT PERFORMANCE EFFORTS
UNDER THE CAL SKILLS PROGRAM.
THE SECOND OBJECTIVE IS TO GO
OVER A REVIEW OF WHAT DATA
COLLECTION AND OUTCOME MEASURES
WOULD BE AUGMENTED IF THE SB 755
PLAN WERE IMPLEMENTED IN FULL
AND I'LL THEN SUMMARIZE THE SB
755 PLAN THAT WAS SUBMITTED TO
THE LEGISLATURE EARLIER THIS
SPRING. OKAY. THANK YOU. PLEASE
PROCEED. I'LL BEGIN WITH THE
OVERVIEW, EDD ADMINISTERS THE
FEDERALLY FUNDED WIOA TITLE ONE
CORE PROGRAMS, WHICH CONSIST OF
ADULT, DISLOCATED WORKER, AND
YOUTH. SO LET ME HAVE YOU MOVE
THAT MICROPHONE A LITTLE. SAME
FOR ALL OF YOU. MOVE JUST CALL
THE WHOLE THING PULLS. THERE WE
GO. VERY GOOD. IS THAT A THAT.
DO THEY HAVE TO TURN UP THE
VOLUME FOR PEOPLE LIKE ME. OH
VERY GOOD, MUCH BETTER. MUCH
BETTER. VERY GOOD. THE FUNDS FOR
THESE PROGRAMS ARE PRIMARILY
MADE UP OF FEDERAL FORMULA
ALLOCATIONS TO THE 45 LOCAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AREAS.
ADDITIONALLY, THE 15% GOVERNOR'S
DISCRETIONARY FUNDS ALLOCATED TO
STATEWIDE WORKFORCE ACTIVITIES
CAN ALSO SUPPORT THIS WORK,
WHILE WHILE FEDERALLY FUNDED,
THESE PROGRAMS OPERATE USING
PROGRAM YEARS OR PIS WHICH RUN
FROM JULY 1ST THROUGH JUNE 30TH.
FROM 2019 THROUGH 2023, NEARLY
1.6 BILLION WAS ALLOCATED FOR
EMPLOYMENT AND TRAINING SERVICES
THROUGH TITLE ONE PROGRAMS. IN
THE MOST RECENT COMPLETE PROGRAM
YEAR PROGRAM YEAR 2022, WHICH
ENDED ON JUNE 30TH, 2023. THE
TITLE ONE PROGRAM EXPENDED. 277
MILLION ON EMPLOYMENT SERVICES,
WHICH CONSISTS OF, LIKE JOB
SEARCH, PLACEMENT ASSISTANCE,
CAREER PLANNING, WORKFORCE
PREPARATION ASSISTANCE AND MORE
THAN 60 MILLION ON TRAINING
SERVICES. NEXT SLIDE. OKAY,
THEY'RE NOT UP ON THE SCREEN
OKAY. VERY GOOD. BUT WE HAVE
THEM. VERY GOOD. I'LL CONTINUE
IF THEY CAN. THEY'RE NOT UP ON
THE SCREEN. DID YOU INTEND FOR
THEM TO BE UP ON OUR SCREEN? WHO
DOES THAT? MIGHT BE HELPFUL FOR
PEOPLE. WHO ARE WATCHING,
SO WHILE WE'RE. WHILE WE'RE
WAITING FOR THEM TO FIGURE THIS
OUT, THE ONE POINT, IT'S AT 1.57
BILLION. AT LEAST IT'S HERE. SO
ABOUT 1.6 BILLION. THAT'S
PRIMARILY FEDERAL MONEY. YES,
THAT'S CORRECT. HOW MUCH OF IT
WAS STATE MONEY? GENERAL FUND,
THAT AMOUNT IS, IS, FEDERAL Þ.
SO IS THERE IS THERE STATE MONEY
ON TOP OF THE 1.57, YES. BUT I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS IN
FRONT. WE COULD GET BACK TO YOU
ON THAT. OKAY PLUS STATE MONEY
TO BE TBD TO BE DETERMINED. YES
OKAY. WE'RE UP NOW, SO. OKAY.
VERY GOOD. ALL RIGHT, VERY GOOD.
EDD USES AN IT SYSTEM KNOWN AS
CAL JOBS AS THE SYSTEM OF RECORD
FOR TITLE ONE CORE PROGRAMS, AND
IS REQUIRED TO REPORT
PARTICIPANT DATA, INCLUDING
OUTCOMES THROUGH THE UNITED
STATES DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING AGENCY ON A
QUARTERLY AND ANNUAL BASIS. DOL
HAS SPECIFIC GUIDELINES FOR
REPORTING, INCLUDING TIMELINES
AND COHORTS TO INCLUDE IN THE
REPORT THE WIOA ANNUAL NARRATIVE
REPORT IS POSTED PUBLICLY BY THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD EACH YEAR AFTER THE REPORT
DEADLINE OF DECEMBER 1ST, AND
THE DOL PUBLISHES DATA FOR
PUBLIC CONSUMPTION ON THEIR
PERFORMANCE RESULTS PAGE. IN
ADDITION TO PARTICIPANT
REPORTING, EDD REPORTS THE
ELIGIBLE TRAINING PROVIDER LIST
KNOWN AS TPL DATA, INCLUDING
OUTCOME DATA TO DWELL ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS VIA THE ELIGIBLE
TRAINING PROVIDER REPORT. THIS
REPORT INCLUDES ALL STUDENTS WE
Þ AND NONWA SERVED BY EACH OF
THE TRAINING PROGRAMS LISTED ON
THE CALIFORNIA ETP. THE
INFORMATION CONTAINED IN THIS
REPORT IS USED ANNUALLY BY LOCAL
AREAS AND THE EDD. WHEN
DETERMINING IF A TRAINING
PROGRAM CAN REMAIN ON THE TPL
ENSURING PROGRAM FUNDS ARE SPENT
ON QUALITY PROGRAMS. NEXT SLIDE.
TITLE ONE CORE PROGRAMS OFFER
EMPLOYMENT AND TRAINING SERVICES
CUSTOMIZED TO THE PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS NEEDS FOR PROGRAM
YEAR. TITLE ONE ONE CORE TITLE
ONE. CORE PROGRAM DATA SHOWS
THAT 64% OF THE PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS RECEIVE ONLY
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES AND ON
AVERAGE, 36% RECEIVE TRAINING
SERVICES, WHICH IS ROUGHLY THREE
PERCENTAGE POINTS HIGHER THAN
THE PROGRAM'S NATIONALLY. AND
THOSE THAT WENT ON TO TRAINING
HAVE A HIGHER ENTERED EMPLOYMENT
RATE AND MEDIAN EARNINGS IN THE
SECOND QUARTER. AFTER EXIT X
AFTER EXITING THE PROGRAM. NEXT
SLIDE. THE TWO EVALUATIONS THAT
WERE RECENTLY CONDUCTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD ON TITLE ONE, DATA CORE
SKILLS 1.0 EVALUATION AND THE
EVALUATION OF THE AMERICA'S JOB
CENTERS OF CALIFORNIA. BOTH
EVALUATIONS CONCLUDED THAT
TRAINING IMPACTS ON EMPLOYMENT
AND EARNINGS ARE POSITIVE AND
STATISTICALLY SIGNIFICANT, BUT
THIS IS IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE P
P 2022 OUTCOME DATA SHOWN ON THE
PREVIOUS SLIDE. ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ON BOTH EVALUATIONS
CAN BE VIEWED ON THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S
WEBSITE. CAN WE ASK A COUPLE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE BAR GRAPH
SLIDE THAT WAS RIGHT BEFORE THIS
ONE? YES. YOU KNOW, I'M NOT NOT
FAMILIAR WITH THIS. SO MY
QUESTION IS A DUMB ONE. I'M SURE
YOU'LL FEEL FREE TO TELL ME MY
SKIN IS PRETTY THICK AFTER 12
YEARS HERE, BUT IT LOOKS LIKE
THEY'RE MORE THE TOTAL PERCENT.
THE TOTAL PARTICIPANTS RECEIVING
JOB TRAINING SERVICES ARE MORE
THAN THE TOTAL PARTICIPANTS. AM
I READING THIS CHART RIGHT? THE
ORANGE LINE IS LONGER THAN THE
BLUE LINE DID, I? AM I MISSING
SOMETHING? I DON'T I DON'T KNOW
HOW YOU'RE Ó. LET ME. YES. ONE
SECOND PLEASE. SO MAYBE YOU HAD
PARTICIPANTS RECEIVING TRAINING.
TWO DIFFERENT TYPES OF TRAINING
MAYBE. YEAH. WHAT THEY WERE
COMPARING WAS THE OUTCOMES FROM
THE TOTAL PARTICIPANTS AND THEN
THE TOTAL PARTICIPANTS THAT
RECEIVE JOB TRAINING
DEMONSTRATING THAT THOSE THAT
RECEIVE TRAINING, THEIR OUTCOMES
WERE HIGHER. SO THAT'S WHY IT
SEEMS LIKE, OH, EMPLOYMENT RATE.
YES. YES YES. SO OKAY. YEAH. SO
BASICALLY, YOU KNOW, IT'S
DEMONSTRATING HOW THOSE THAT GOT
TRAINING EXCEEDED THE OUTCOMES
EXCEEDED THOSE THAT ONLY RECEIVE
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES. AND TO THE
POINT OF SENATE BILL 755, I
GUESS THE PROBLEM WITH THIS DATA
IS WE DON'T KNOW WHAT KIND OF
EMPLOYMENT. YES, FOR THE MOST
PART, SO WE COULD BE TRAINING.
WE COULD BE TRAINING A DENTAL
ASSISTANT WHO THEN GOES TO WORK
IN A STARBUCKS. WELL, WE DO HAVE
DATA AS FAR AS WHERE PEOPLE GET
TRAINED AND SO ON, YOU COULD
JUST. WELL, I'M JUMPING INTO
SOMEBODY ELSE'S SANDBOX. YEAH.
OKAY. BUT SO YOU CAN JUST DEFER
THE QUESTION THEN TO SOMEBODY
ELSE TO ANSWER. BUT MY POINT IS,
I MEAN, WE KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
TRAINED IN AND, AND WE REPORT AS
SOMEBODY SOMEWHERE IN HERE I SEE
YOU WE REPORT CERTIFICATES OR
CREDENTIALS OBTAINED. SO WE KNOW
SOMEONE FINISHED A DENTAL
HYGIENE TRAINING PROGRAM. RIGHT
BUT OUR DATA CORRECT ME, OUR
DATA IS NOT SUFFICIENT FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO TELL WHETHER THAT
PERSON GOT A JOB IN A DENTIST
OFFICE AS A DENTAL HYGIENIST,
RIGHT? THAT'S CORRECT. WELL, WE
DO KNOW IS THEY GOT THEY
RECEIVED A CREDENTIAL AFTER
TRAINING AND THEY HAVE INCOME.
THAT'S RIGHT. AND THE INCOME IS
REPORTED. THAT'S RIGHT, THAT'S
RIGHT. SO THAT'S THE DISCONNECT
BETWEEN THE EFFICACY OF THE
TRAINING PROGRAM IN TERMS OF JOB
PLACEMENT. RIGHT. WE DON'T KNOW
IF IN FACT THEY'RE WORKING IN
THE FIELD THEY WERE TRAINED IN.
WE DON'T KNOW THE AMOUNT OF
HOURS THEY'RE WORKING IN THE IN
THAT GIVEN TIME PERIOD AND SO
ON. THAT THAT IS THE DISCONNECT
CURRENTLY. I THINK THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WOULD WANT THAT TOO,
GIVEN THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT
THEY SHOVE IN THE PIPELINE DOWN
TO US. RIGHT? YES. AND I WOULD
SAY THAT, WE'RE HOPEFUL THERE'S
STATE NATIONALLY, THERE'S
INCREASED INTEREST IN, IN, IN
THIS INFORMATION. SO WE'RE
HOPING EVENTUALLY THE FEDERAL
THE FEDS WILL CONSIDER FUNDING
SUCH, SUCH A THING. WE LIKE THAT
WE'LL SHARE THAT OCCUR. I
DERAILED PARTIALLY YOUR TRAIN SO
YOU CAN FIRE IT BACK UP AGAIN.
YEAH NEXT. ARE YOU FINISHED? I
BELIEVE I'M DONE. AT THIS
JUNCTURE, I WILL TURN OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE BC FROM THE
CALIFORNIA. WELL, FIRST OF ALL.
RIGHT. RIGHT NOW, I'M HERE.
THANK YOU. JAVIER. GOOD MORNING.
CHAIR. MORNING MEMBERS, THANKS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. I'LL START
WITH THE CDB PROGRAM OVERVIEW,
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
ADMINISTERS SEVERAL GRANT
PROGRAMS THAT FUND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND NONPROFITS TO
HELP HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED
POPULATIONS TRAIN FOR AND OBTAIN
FAMILY SUSTAINING CAREERS. THESE
GRANTS COME FROM A COMBINATION
OF STATE AND FEDERAL DOLLARS AND
ARE AWARDED COMPETITIVELY. KWBW
CURRENTLY MANAGES ABOUT 350
MILLION IN GRANTS, WHICH ARE
EXPECTED TO SERVE ABOUT 47,000
CALIFORNIANS, OF WHICH 62% WILL
RECEIVE JOB TRAINING. ALL THE
REMAINING FUNDS ARE ENCUMBERED
FOR DIFFERENT KWBW PROGRAMS.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. WHEN WE MOVED
INTO MANAGING PROGRAMS, THE ONLY
SOURCE OF DATA CAPTURE WAS CAL
JOBS, AS A NUMBER OF PROGRAMS
AND PARTICIPANTS EXPANDED, THERE
WAS A NEED FOR CREATING ITS OWN
DATA CAPTURE SYSTEM WITH
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT A LONG TERM,
STABLE AND SECURE DATA CAPTURE
SYSTEM. WE CREATED AN INTERIM
SOLUTION CALLED SGDS STATE GRANT
DATA SOLUTIONS AND FURTHER
DESIGNED A ROBUST SALESFORCE
BASED SYSTEM CALLED CAL GRANTS,
WHICH WAS ROLLED OUT OVER THE
LAST SIX MONTHS. EACH GRANT
PROGRAM HAS ITS OWN STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS FOR PERFORMANCE
REPORTING, AND ALSO THE WAGE
MATCHING REQUIRES A ONE YEAR LAG
TIME. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. THIS
SLIDE SHOWS THE PERFORMANCE DATA
FOR THE PROGRAM YEAR 2021 2022
ACROSS THREE KEY CDB PROGRAMS P
TO E PERSON TO EMPLOYMENT, HIGH
ROAD CONSTRUCTION CARRIERS, HRC
AND HIGH ROAD TRAINING
PARTNERSHIP HTTP. COLLECTIVELY,
ABOUT 62% OF THE PARTICIPANTS
SERVED RECEIVED JOB TRAINING.
NOTABLY, A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
P2P PARTICIPANTS. CGRTS HAD
ALREADY EARNED INDUSTRY
RECOGNIZED CREDENTIALS FROM JOB
TRAINING THEY RECEIVED WHILE
INCARCERATED. PROGRAM FUNDING IS
ALSO FOCUSED ON PROVIDING
SERVICES TO SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS
REENTERING THE WORKFORCE IN MOST
CASES, PARTICIPANTS WHO RECEIVED
JOB TRAINING FARED BETTER IN THE
LABOR MARKET. FOR EXAMPLE, THE
SECOND QUARTER EMPLOYMENT RATE
AMONG HTTP PARTICIPANTS WAS
70.2, AND THAT NUMBER WAS ABOUT
FIVE PERCENTAGE POINTS HIGHER
AMONG THOSE WHO COMPLETED
TRAINING. FURTHERMORE THE SECOND
QUARTER MEDIAN WAGE AMONG HTTP
PARTICIPANTS WAS 13,007 61, AND
THAT NUMBER WAS ABOUT $1,500
HIGHER. AMONG THOSE WHO
COMPLETED TRAINING. NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. CLOUDBEES INDEPENDENT
EVALUATION STRATEGY IS FOCUSED
ON CONTINUOUSLY IMPROVING
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE,
WORKFORCE SYSTEM, AND THIRD
PARTY EVALUATIONS OF OUR GRANT
PROGRAMS ARE KEY TO THIS EFFORT.
THESE EVALUATIONS REPORT
TYPICALLY EXAMINE BEST PRACTICES
FOR SERVING HISTORICALLY
MARGINALIZED POPULATIONS. RECENT
EVALUATIONS HAVE HELPED UNCOVER
WHAT EXACTLY WORKS. THAT IS, A
TRAINING THAT LEADS TO A
CREDENTIAL EARLY REINTEGRATION
INTO THE LABOR MARKET AND
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES, WHICH
INCLUDES EMOTIONAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL SUPPORT. NEXT
SLIDE, PLEASE. WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD DESIGNED A
ROBUST DATA PLATFORM CALLED
CROSS SYSTEMS ANALYTICS AND
ASSESSMENTS FOR LEARNING AND
SKILLS ATTAINMENT. IN SHORT, CAL
SKILLS. IT WAS ESTABLISHED TO
SATISFY UIC SECTION 14 013,
WHICH REQUIRES KWBW TO DEVELOP A
WORKFORCE METRICS DASHBOARD THAT
MEASURES INVESTMENTS IN
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THEIR IMPACT ON THE
LABOR MARKET. CALS SKILLS IS A
MULTI-DEPARTMENTAL AND
INTERAGENCY EFFORT THAT
INTEGRATES, EVALUATES, AND
REPORTS DATA FROM 13 WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS ACROSS
EIGHT DATA SHARING PARTNERS. CAL
SKILLS REPORTING INCLUDES
DESCRIPTIVE STATISTICS AND
SUMMARY ANALYSIS VIA WORKFORCE
METRICS DASHBOARD REPORT AS WELL
AS STATISTICALLY RIGOROUS
EVALUATION OF PROGRAM IMPACT ON
PARTICIPANT OUTCOMES VIA CPL
REPORT, WHICH IS A CALIFORNIA
POLICY LAB. WHO IS OUR ACADEMIC
EVALUATION PARTNER? NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. KANSEN USES COMMON
PERFORMANCE MEASURES TO EXAMINE
PARTICIPANT CHARACTERISTICS.
PARTICIPANT OUTCOME AND OTHER
WORKFORCE SYSTEM FACTORS,
INCLUDING SERVICES PROVIDED,
PROVIDER LOCATION AND INDUSTRY
OF EMPLOYMENT. METRICS ARE
CURRENTLY INFORMED BY DEPARTMENT
OF LABOR REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
AND UI CODE 14 013, WHICH
INCLUDES TOTAL NUMBER OF
PARTICIPANTS SERVED, EXITED AND
COMPLETED TRAINING FOR A FISCAL
YEAR, AND ALSO THE PERCENTAGE
EMPLOYED SECOND AND FOURTH
QUARTER AFTER EXIT. MEDIAN
QUARTERLY EARNINGS, SECOND AND
FOURTH QUARTERS AFTER EXIT, AND
THE PERCENTAGE ATTAINED
CREDENTIAL FOURTH QUARTER AFTER
EXIT. I'LL STOP HERE. THANKS FOR
LISTENING, AND I'LL PASS IT TO
MY COLLEAGUE JENNIFER STURDY TO
GO OVER THE SB 755 DETAILS.
THANK. LET ME LET ME ASK A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS ON YOUR
FIRST OVERVIEW SLIDE, FUNDING
FROM THIS IS P. 2019 20 TO 2324
I GUESS $540.8 MILLION, IT SAYS,
DOES NOT INCLUDE PASSTHROUGHS.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN. JUST
LOOKING AT THIS SLIDE. THIS IS
THE OVERVIEW SLIDE 540.8 MILLION
FUNDING FOR THOSE YEARS DOES NOT
INCLUDE PASTORS IS WHAT'S THE
PASS THROUGH. IS THAT FEDERAL
PASS THROUGH, SORRY IF I COULD
STEP IN. THOSE ARE STATE FUNDED
PROGRAMS THAT GO THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD. ARE NOT THEY'RE NOT
ISSUED THROUGH COMPETITIVE AWARD
PROCESS OR SOLICITATIONS THROUGH
EARMARKS, OTHER EARMARKS. BUT
THEY'RE EARMARKS OUT OF THE
GENERAL FUND FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. I MEAN, THIS IS
THIS IS PROGRAM FUNDING. SO
SOMEBODY JUST GAVE SOMEBODY
$540.8 MILLION, RIGHT? YES AND
THEN THEY'RE PASSTHROUGHS. ARE
THE PASSTHROUGHS OVER AND ABOVE
THE $540.8 MILLION? YES. AND
THOSE ARE OUT OF THE STATE
GENERAL FUND. I THINK A VARIETY
OF, SOURCES OF FUNDING, HOW MUCH
DOES THAT ENTAIL? THE, THE MAIN
SHARE OF THIS FUND IS COMING
FROM THE WIOA, A 15 PERCENTAGE
DISCRETIONARY FUND. AND THE PASS
THROUGH WHICH YOU MENTIONED I
CAN I CAN GET YOU THE BREAKDOWN
OF WHAT EXACTLY THAT IS. ALL
RIGHT. BECAUSE WHAT I'M TRYING
TO GET A HANDLE ON IS HOW MUCH
MONEY WE SPEND ON WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT, TRAINING AND OTHER
THINGS, BUT PRIMARILY TRAINING.
AND THE REASON IT'S DIFFICULT, I
GUESS, FOR ME TO GET A HANDLE ON
IT IS THERE ARE SO MANY BUCKETS
COMING FROM SO MANY DIFFERENT
DIRECTIONS, AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW WHAT THE TOTAL
IS BECAUSE THE REPORTING THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. IMPACTS
WERE INVOLVES THE TOTAL. SO WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A BUDGETARY
EXPENDITURE TO GET THE SYSTEMS
UP AND RUNNING OF 25 MILLION OR
50 MILLION OR WHATEVER IT TURNS
OUT TO BE, YOU HAVE TO MEASURE
THAT AGAINST THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
ROLLING THROUGH THE SYSTEM OVER
TIME, RIGHT? THAT'S CORRECT. YES
SO IT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO KNOW
WHAT THAT EXTRA MONEY, WHAT IT
TOTALS AND WHERE IT COMES FROM.
I SUPPOSE WE COULD LOOK AT THE
BUDGET, BUT THE BUDGET, YOU KNOW
HOW MANY VOLUMES THAT IS. AND
WE'D HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WHERE
THE LINE ITEMS ARE AND WHAT THEY
ARE. AND YOU ALL PROBABLY HAVE A
BETTER WAY TO COMPUTE THAT THAN
ME. THE 46.6 THOUSAND ACTIVE
CURRENT AWARDS ARE THOSE. IS
THAT THE NUMBER OF PARTICIPANTS
IN THE C.W.D PROGRAM THAT'S
THAT'S CURRENTLY BEING RECORDED
IN THE CDB PROGRAM. SO THOSE ARE
NUMBER OF PARTICIPANTS. YES. AND
WE DIDN'T GET THAT FROM THE WIOA
SLIDE I DON'T THINK I MISSED IT.
MAYBE SOMEBODY CAN GO OVER THAT
WHEN WE GO BACK. I DIDN'T SEE
THE NUMBER OF PARTICIPANTS IN
THE VARIOUS WIOA PROGRAMS. THAT
WAS ONE OF THE QUESTIONS THAT WE
ASKED. TAKING A LOOK AT YOUR
SLIDES, I, I'M SOMEBODY'S GOING
TO HAVE TO EDUCATE ME AFTER THIS
HEARING AS TO WHAT THE SECOND
QUARTER EMPLOYMENT RATE. SO DOES
THIS SLIDE REFLECT THE FACT THAT
SOME PARTICIPANTS ONLY SEEK
SERVICES FOR EMPLOYMENT BUT NOT
TRAINING AND EMPLOYMENT? IS THAT
WHY THE ORANGE IS 55.2% AND THE
BLUE IS 58.1? YEAH, THAT THAT'S
SPECIFICALLY FOR, THE P TO E
PROGRAM, WHICH OUR RESEARCHERS
ALSO LOOKED AT IT BECAUSE THE,
THE PARTICIPANT GOT TRAINED, THE
AMOUNT IS LESS. THAT'S BECAUSE
THE, THE, THE TRAINING THAT THE
PARTICIPANT WENT THROUGH WHILE
THEY WERE INCARCERATED WAS, WAS
THAT THAT TRAINING GOT THEM INTO
THE LABOR MARKET AND THEY GOT
EMPLOYED. BUT THOSE PARTICIPANTS
WHO GOT TRAINING RIGHT AFTER,
WHEN THEY CAME OUT, THEY THEY
WERE DELAYED IN GETTING SO THAT
THAT IS THE DISCREPANCY THAT YOU
SEE THERE, I SEE. OKAY. THANK
YOU. THANKS FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION.
NOW THE CATSKILLS, SYSTEM
REFRESH ME IS THAT UP AND
RUNNING? IT IS THERE WE ARE IN
THE PROCESS OF, RE-ENGINE DOING
THE COMPLETE CATSKILLS, THE
CATSKILLS ASSESS THE LEGACY
CATSKILL SYSTEM EXISTS NOW, WE
ARE MIGRATING THAT ENTIRE SYSTEM
INTO CLOUD. AWS GOV CLOUD.
THAT'S PHASE TWO, RIGHT? IT'S A
PHASE TWO. CORRECT. AND WE HAVE
A PHASE THREE, PHASE THREE WILL
HAVE I MEAN, WE ARE ANTICIPATING
WE ARE HOPING THAT SP 755 WILL
BE A PART OF THAT. AND OUR FIRST
SET OF CATSKILLS REPORT CAME OUT
FROM OUR PROTOTYPE CATSKILLS
VERSION ONE. AND THE SECOND
VERSION IS WHAT CURRENTLY WE ARE
MIGRATING TO THE CLOUD AND WE
HAVE RE-ENGINEERED THE DATABASE
IN SUCH A WAY THAT IT CAN
ACCOMMODATE ANY KIND OF,
VARIABLE DATA THAT COMES FROM
DIFFERENT PARTNERS, CURRENTLY WE
HAVE LIKE 13 PROGRAMS SENDING US
DATA, AND IT'S ALL IN
NON-UNIFORM FORMAT WITH, WITH
THE NEW SYSTEM, WE CAME UP WITH
THE STANDARD UNIFORM LAYOUT IN
SUCH A WAY THAT THEY CAN PROVIDE
THE DATA IN THAT STANDARD LAYOUT
, AND IT CAN GET INTO THE SYSTEM
WITHOUT ANY MUCH MANUAL WORK.
NOW, I NOTICED IN THE SIX ITEMS
THAT YOU HAVE ON YOUR SLIDE IN
TERMS OF THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND METRICS, WE
HAVE MEDIAN QUARTERLY EARNINGS.
SECOND AND FOURTH QUARTER AFTER
EXIT AND, PERCENTAGE CREDENTIAL
FOR QUARTERS AFTER EXIT. IS THIS
CATSKILLS SYSTEM ABLE TO DO ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE HOPE TO
ACCOMPLISH WITH SENATE BILL 755
AND THE IMPLEMENTATION IS TO GET
SOME IDEA OF CAREER PROGRESSION,
NOT ONLY REGIONAL LIVING WAGES,
BUT CAREER PROGRESSION OVER A
CAREER, YOU KNOW, GETTING DATA
AT CERTAIN PHASE POINTS MORE
THAN JUST THE FIRST QUARTER
AFTER THE TRAINING. YES. IS YOUR
CORE SKILL SYSTEM ABLE TO DO
THAT, NOT NOT WITH THE CURRENT
SET OF DATA THAT WE, WE ARE
RECEIVING WITH THE ADDITIONAL
DATA THAT WE MAY RECEIVE WITH
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SB 755.
YES, THAT IS POSSIBLE. I SEE,
BUT THE SYSTEM ITSELF CAN CAN
GENERATE MEDIAN QUARTERLY
EARNINGS OVER A PERIOD OF TIME
FOR A PARTICULAR GROUPS OF
PEOPLE. YES AND ONE OTHER
QUESTION THAT GOES TO SORT OF
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN CAL
SKILLS, THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD, AND THE WIOA
REPORTING. HOW DOES ALL THAT
RELATE? I MEAN, DOES CAL SKILLS
DO IT ALL FOR THE WIOA PROGRAMS
AS WELL? IS THAT A FAIR
QUESTION, AM I GOING TO GET A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT REPORTS?
YEAH. WHETHER IT'S WORKFORCE,
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT OR WIOA.
YEAH. THERE ARE TWO REPORTS THAT
COMES OUT OF THE CAL SKILLS. ONE
IS THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
WORKFORCE DASH METRICS DASHBOARD
REPORT. AND THE SECOND ONE IS
THE STATISTICALLY RIGOROUS
EVALUATION DONE BY CALIFORNIA
POLICY LAB. SO THE DASHBOARD
REPORT WILL HAVE ALL THESE
MEASURES THAT THAT HAS BEEN
LISTED HERE. AND THE ANALYSIS
REPORT THAT COMES FROM,
CALIFORNIA POLICY LAB WILL HAVE
MORE, DETAILED DESCRIPTIVE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHICH PROGRAM
DID, BETTER FOR A GIVEN PROGRAM
YEAR. AND AND WHAT ARE THE
MEASURES THAT WE NEED TO TAKE IN
ORDER TO GO TO THE NEXT LEVEL?
LET ME ASK IT ANOTHER WAY,
BECAUSE YOU CAN TELL THAT I'M
NOT I DIDN'T NEVER CHAIRED THE
LABOR COMMITTEE HERE. SO I DON'T
GET INVOLVED TYPICALLY IN THESE
ISSUES EXCEPT THIS ONE INTERESTS
ME. SO WE HAVE 1.57 BILLION OVER
A PERIOD OF YEARS, AND WE HAVE A
500 AND SOMETHING MILLION AT THE
BOARD LEVEL OVER THE SAME,
APPARENTLY THE SAME PERIOD OF
YEARS, IS THIS CAL SKILLS WHEN
IT'S FULLY IMPLEMENTED, WHETHER
IT'S PHASE TWO, PHASE THREE,
WHATEVER, WILL IT TAKE? ALL THE
PROGRAMS FUNDED BY $2 BILLION
AND DELIVER DATA, OR IS IT GOING
TO BE CHIMNEYED STOVEPIPED? AS
WE SAY, CAL SKILLS WILL
ACCOMMODATE ALL THE EXISTING
PROGRAMS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
THERE IN CAL SKILLS, PLUS ALL
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
PROGRAMS THAT ARE NOT CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE IN CAL SKILL SYSTEM.
SO THAT THAT'S A PLAN. SO 13,
PROGRAMS THAT CURRENTLY CAL
SKILLS ACCOMMODATE PLUS ALL THE
CDB PROGRAMS ARE THERE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS OUTSIDE OF
WHAT YOU JUST DESCRIBED THAT
WILL NOT BE CAPTURED BY CAL
SKILLS, I'M NOT AWARE ABOUT THAT
, I CAN I CAN FIND OUT. IS THAT
AN INTELLIGENT QUESTION? YOU CAN
TELL ME. NO, I'M JUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT. ARE WE GOING TO HAVE
ONE SYSTEM THAT PRODUCES A
REPORTS OF SOMEONE LIKE ME CAN
LOOK AT POWERPOINT SLIDES LIKE
THIS AND UNDERSTAND WHERE WE'RE
SPENDING OUR MONEY AND WHETHER
WHETHER THE DATA POINTS THAT
WE'VE REFERENCED IN SB 755 OR
EVEN THE DATA POINTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY LISTED UNDER CAL
SKILLS. WHAT THE DATA IS, YOU'RE
ASKING THE RIGHT QUESTION. I
MEAN, CAL SKILLS AS A CURRENT
SYSTEM HAS A CURRENT SCOPE OF
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
THAT ARE WITHIN IT. THAT'S WHAT
I THOUGHT. AND THAT SCOPE
CURRENTLY DOES NOT INCLUDE THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD PROGRAMS THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN IMPLEMENTING. AND SO THAT'S
WHY IN SB 755 PLAN, IT'S PART OF
THE ADDITIONAL RESOURCE NEEDS TO
EXPAND THE SCOPE OF CAL SKILLS
TO INCLUDE THOSE ADDITIONAL
PROGRAMS. AND THAT'S PART OF
YOUR PRESENTATION. AND I CAN
CERTAINLY WAIT FOR THAT. BUT YOU
KNOW, MY GOAL, NOT THAT I GET TO
HAVE ONE, BUT I'M GOING TO HAVE
ONE. MY GOAL IS THAT ALL OF THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
WILL FEED DATA, WHATEVER THE
DATA POINTS. ULTIMATELY WIND UP
BEING INTO A SYSTEM, AN IT
SYSTEM THAT IS ABLE TO TELL US
AND ANSWER THE QUESTIONS THAT I
THINK NEED TO BE ASKED. YOU
KNOW, WHO'S YOU KNOW HOW MANY
ARE BEING TRAINED, WHAT THEIR
WHAT THE TRAINING IS? DOES THE
TRAINING MATCH UP WITH ACTUAL
JOBS THAT THE PEOPLE GET AT THE
END OF THE PIPELINE? WHAT'S THE
WHAT'S THE WHAT WAGES ARE THEY
EARNING? ARE THEY WHAT WE WOULD
CALL LIVING WAGES FOR REGIONS IN
THE STATE TO BE DETERMINED AND
THEN ULTIMATELY, ULTIMATELY THE
TRAINING LEADING TO JOBS, TO THE
JOBS, PROVIDE THE TYPE OF CAREER
PATH THAT WE WANT FOR PEOPLE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHICH
WOULD SHOW OR WOULD DEMONSTRATE
IN THE FORM OF INCREMENTAL
INCREASES IN WAGES OVER TIME,
REGARDLESS OF THE SOURCE OF THE
FUNDING AND REGARDLESS OF WHICH
AGENCY, DEPARTMENT OR BOARD IS
ADMINISTERING THE FUNDING AND
THE GRANTS AND ALL OF THAT,
THAT'S WHAT I HOPE TO SEE. AND I
GUESS YOU'RE GOING TO BE TALKING
ABOUT THAT, RIGHT, MA'AM?
HOPEFULLY. YES I THINK I THINK
THAT'S ALL THE QUESTIONS I HAVE
RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU. WELCOME,
SENATOR CHOBOQ. MORNING,
SENATOR. OKAY. WHO'S NEXT?
THANKS PK. I'LL TAKE US TO THE
SECOND OBJECTIVE OF THE PANEL,
SO I'LL NOW PROVIDE A REVIEW OF
WHAT DATA COLLECTION AND OUTCOME
MEASURES WOULD BE AUGMENTED IF
THE SB 755 PLAN WERE IMPLEMENTED
, AND IN FULL, A REMINDER THAT
SB 755 INTENTION IS TO BUILD ON
THE EXISTING DATA INFRASTRUCTURE
TO COLLECT MORE DATA RELATED TO
JOB TRAINING. PARTICIPANT
OUTCOMES FOR WIOA TITLE ONE
PROGRAMS MANAGED BY EDD AND KWBW
PROGRAMS, AS WELL AS TO IDENTIFY
THE NECESSARY RESOURCES TO ADD
THAT DATA COLLECTION. OAN. SO
FAR, WE'VE TALKED ABOUT EXISTING
DATA INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
WORKFORCE PARTICIPANT DATA
SYSTEMS SUCH AS IDS CAL JOBS. IN
ADDITION, YOU'VE ALREADY RAISED
THE BASE WAGE FILE, WHICH IS
MANAGED BY EDD AND IS ANOTHER
EXISTING DATA INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT ANALYSTS RELY ON FOR ACTUAL
EMPLOYMENT AND EARNINGS. OVER
TIME. THIS DATA IS SUBMITTED BY
ALL EMPLOYERS IN THE STATE AND
IS PRIMARILY USED TO CALCULATE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AND OTHER
BENEFITS, SO WHAT DATA
COLLECTION ANALYSIS WOULD BE
NEEDED IF OUTCOME MEASURES WERE
EXPANDED? WE HAVE FOUR DIFFERENT
EXPANSION POTENTIAL EXPANSIONS.
THE FIRST ONE IS TRAINING
RELATED EMPLOYMENT TO DO
TRAINING RELATED EMPLOYMENT, WE
NEED THE OCCUPATION OF THE
TRAINING WHICH WE HAVE IN OUR
PARTICIPANT DATA SYSTEMS. WE
WOULD ALSO NEED THE OCCUPATION
OF EMPLOYMENT, WHICH WE DO NOT
HAVE IN THE BASE WAGE FILE. THE
SECOND ELEMENT WE ARE ASKED TO
COMPARE PARTICIPANT EARNINGS
AGAINST A SPECIFIC REGIONAL
LIVING WAGE DEFINITION. TO DO
THIS, WE WOULD REQUIRE DEFINING
WHAT IS A REGIONAL LIVING WAGE.
WE WOULD ALSO REQUIRE MEDIAN
QUARTERLY EARNINGS, WHICH WE
CURRENTLY CAN OBTAIN OVER TIME
FROM THE BASE WAGE FILE.
HOWEVER, WE WOULD ALSO NEED
HOURS WORKED, THE REGION WHERE
THE INDIVIDUAL IS WORKING AND
THE REGION WHERE THE INDIVIDUAL
LIVES. IN ORDER TO FULLY
CALCULATE THE LIVING WAGE THAT
THOSE ELEMENTS ARE NOT CURRENTLY
IN THE BASE WAGE FILE. THIRD, WE
ARE ASKED TO TRACK UPWARD
MOBILITY OF JOB TRAINING
PARTICIPANTS OVER TIME BY
EXPANDING WHEN WE MEASURE THEIR
EMPLOYMENT AND EARNINGS.
ACCORDING TO SB 755, THIS WOULD
BE UP TO ONE YEAR BEFORE
TRAINING TAKES PLACE AND UP TO
THREE YEARS AFTER TRAINING. THIS
REQUIRES EXPANDING HOW LONG AND
HOW OFTEN ANALYSTS MERGE.
PARTICIPANT DATA TO THE BASE
WAGE FILE TO TRACK UNEMPLOYMENT
AND EARNINGS OVER TIME. THIS IS
FEASIBLE TO DO WITH OUR EXISTING
DATA SYSTEM, AND IN FACT WAS
ALREADY DONE IN THE CAL SKILLS
1.0 EVALUATION ANALYSIS THAT WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER, WHERE
FINALLY, WE ARE ASKED TO COMPARE
THE DIFFERENCES IN OUTCOMES FOR
JOB TRAINING PARTICIPANTS FOR BI
Kò CHARACTERISTICS, SUCH AS THE
TRAINING PROVIDER WHO DELIVERED
THE SERVICE, THE REGION, THE JOB
TRAINING TOOK PLACE, AS WELL AS
THE INDUSTRY AND OCCUPATION OF
THE TRAINING. ALL THESE DATA
POINTS ARE IN OUR EXISTING
PARTICIPANT DATA SYSTEM SO WE
CAN DO THIS ANALYSIS. THE
BIGGEST CONSTRAINT TO THIS
ANALYSIS IS BASED ON PROGRAM'S
SCOPE AND THE ACTUAL SAMPLE
SIZES WITHIN THE DATA. FOR
EXAMPLE, IT CAN BE CHALLENGING
TO DO REGIONAL ANALYSIS OF A
SPECIFIC PROGRAM ONLY OPERATED
IN 1 OR 2 REGIONS. WHAT'S
OCCUPATION OF TRAINING MEAN? I
SEE THAT THAT'S AT THE TOP AND
AT THE BOTTOM OF THIS PARTICULAR
SLIDE. DOES THAT MEAN WE'RE
TRAINING SOMEBODY TO BE I'LL USE
MY DENTAL HYGIENIST EXAMPLE.
EXACTLY. SO BUT THE CONNECTION
ON THIS LAST ONE IS NOT
NECESSARILY OCCUPATION AND
TRAINING, BUT OCCUPATION AND
EMPLOYMENT. RIGHT. FOR THE LAST
ONE IT IS THE WE WANT TO FIND
OUT IF SOMEBODY ACTUALLY GETS A
JOB AS A HYGIENIST, BECAUSE OF
COURSE IT'S BEEN A LITTLE BIT OF
TIME SINCE I'VE SEEN AN ARTICLE
IN THE NEWSPAPER. BUT THERE WERE
THESE ANECDOTAL STORIES ABOUT
WE'RE TRAINING, YOU KNOW, 250,
CODERS IN SAN DIEGO. AND THERE
THERE ARE TEN JOBS AVAILABLE FOR
THE 250. WE'VE JUST SPENT
TRAINING, AND NOW THAT WAS AN
ARTICLE I DON'T MY NUMBERS WERE
PROBABLY A LITTLE OFF, BUT NOT
BY MUCH. WE SEEMS TO ME AS A
STATE, WE WANT TO TRY TO AVOID
THAT BECAUSE THAT'S A LOT OF
MONEY. I WON'T SAY WASTED, BUT
WE SPENT A LOT OF MONEY TRAINING
PEOPLE FOR JOBS THAT APPARENTLY
DON'T EXIST. THERE MAYBE THEY
EXIST SOMEWHERE. SO WE NEED TO
MOVE OCCUPATION AND TRAINING
DATA IS IMPORTANT, BUT WE ALSO
NEED OCCUPATION AND EMPLOYMENT
DATA. YES AND THAT IS THE FIRST,
DATA ELEMENT THAT WAS MENTIONED.
SO MAKING SURE THAT WE CAN
MEASURE TRAINING RELATED
EMPLOYMENT PLACEMENT AND
WOULDN'T THE SAMPLE SIZE
WOULDN'T IT BE LARGE ENOUGH TO
DETERMINE FIRST? SO FOR SOME
PROGRAMS IT DEPENDS ON THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF PARTICIPANTS WHERE IT
OPERATED, HOW MANY INDUSTRIES OR
OCCUPATIONS INDIVIDUALS WERE
TRAINED ON. WHENEVER YOU WANT TO
CUT THE DATA MORE AND MORE WAYS,
IT GETS SMALLER AND SMALLER. SO
JUST FLAGGING THAT ANY SORT OF
DISAGGREGATION OF ANALYSIS BY
THAT MANY ELEMENTS CAN START
FACING SAMPLE SIZE ISSUES. OKAY
I DIDN'T MEAN TO TOTALLY
INTERRUPT, BUT I DID. THANK YOU
THOUGH. OKAY, WITH THAT, I'LL
MOVE TO THE LAST, OBJECTIVE OF
THE PANEL, TO PROVIDE A SUMMARY
OF THE SB 755 PLAN THAT WAS
SUBMITTED, THE LABOR AGENCY, ED
AND KWBW STAFF WORKED
COLLABORATIVELY SINCE JANUARY
2023 TO DELIVER ON THE SB 755
PLAN. FIRST, WE WANT TO FLAG
THERE ARE EXISTING WORK STREAMS
AND RESOURCES THAT SUPPORT ED
AND QUBE'S WORKFORCE PERFORMANCE
ANALYSIS AND EVALUATION EFFORTS
THAT ARE RELEVANT TO SB 755. FOR
EXAMPLE, IN 2023, LABOR AGENCY
AND SB 755 WORKING GROUP LED AND
COMPLETED SEVERAL RELEVANT WORK
STREAMS, SUCH AS ESTABLISHING A
CENTRALIZED WORKFORCE PROGRAM
INVENTORY. EXACTLY TO YOUR
POINT, TO KIND OF KNOW THE SCOPE
OF ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS, ALSO SET
DEFINED A SET OF WORKFORCE
COMMON METRICS, RELY ON INPUT
FROM THE SB 755, EXPANDED
OUTCOMES, AS WELL AS EXISTING
PERFORMANCE METRICS THAT ARE IN
UI CODE 14 ZERO 13, AS WELL AS
REVIEWING ALL THE EXISTING
PARTICIPANT DATA SYSTEMS FOR
ALIGNMENT WITH THE DATA ELEMENTS
THAT ARE REQUIRED TO REPORT ON
THOSE METRICS. NEXT SLIDE. IN
2023, KWBW AND THE WORKING GROUP
LED THE ASSESSMENT OF THE
EXISTING CAL SKILLS PROGRAM AND
ITS DATA INFRASTRUCTURE SYSTEM
FOR RELEVANCE TO SB 755. AS
PRESENTED IN THE PLAN, KWBW IS
CURRENTLY MODERNIZING THE CAL
SKILLS SYSTEM TO MOVE TO A
SECURE, CLOUD BASED ENVIRONMENT.
IMPROVED DATA INTAKE AND
STANDARDIZATION, AND PRODUCE AN
INTERACTIVE PUBLIC FACING
DASHBOARD, ALL OF WHICH ALIGN
WITH THE ORIGINAL PERFORMANCE
ANALYSIS ELEMENTS THAT ARE
DEFINED IN UI CODE 14 ZERO 13.
SO MOVING TOWARD, A STRONGER
SYSTEM, BUT STILL ONE THAT'S
BUILT AROUND THE ORIGINAL
PERFORMANCE METRICS THAT GUIDED
CAL SKILLS. IN ADDITION, IN
2023, KWBW CO-CREATED THE SECOND
PHASE OF THE CAL SKILLS
EVALUATION ANALYSIS WITH THEIR
ACADEMIC RESEARCH PARTNER, THE
CALIFORNIA POLICY LAB. THE SCOPE
OF THE WORKFORCE PROGRAMS
CONTINUES TO INCLUDE THAT
ORIGINAL SCOPE FROM CAL SKILLS,
WHICH PK LISTED EARLIER BEFORE
THE SECOND PHASE EVALUATION
ANALYSIS. SCOPE OF WORK.
REFERENCES. EXPANDED OUTCOMES
SUCH AS UPWARD MOBILITY AND
DISAGGREGATION ELEMENTS SUCH AS
TRAINING PROVIDER REGION,
INDUSTRY, AND OCCUPATION AND
REQUESTS. THESE ARE INCLUDED IN
ANALYSIS AS FEASIBLE BASED ON
SAMPLE SIZES AND DATA
AVAILABILITY. VÆ. THE SECOND
PHASE EVALUATION EFFORT IS
ALREADY FUNDED THROUGH WIOA 15,
AND THE CONTRACTING PROCESS HAS
BEGUN WITH AN EXPECTED PERIOD OF
PERFORMANCE FROM SUMMER 2024 TO
SUMMER 2027. FINALLY IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE BILL, THE
WORKING GROUP IDENTIFIED THE
ACTIVITIES COSTS AND TIMELINES
THAT WOULD BE REQUIRED TO ADAPT
THESE EXISTING SYSTEMS TO ALIGN
WITH THE EXPANDED REQUIREMENTS
OF SB 755. AS NOTED AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE SLIDE,
IMPLEMENTING THE SB 75 PLAN AS
WRITTEN WOULD REQUIRE 25.4
MILLION IN 1 TIME COSTS AND
WOULD REQUIRE BETWEEN 5.6 AND
9.4 MILLION IN ANNUAL COST TO
MAINTAIN THE CHANGES. THE
LARGEST COSTS ARE ATTRIBUTED TO
THE EXPANSION OF THE BASE WAGE
FILE. WE'VE MENTIONED EARLIER,
SO THAT IT CAN INCLUDE THE
ADDITIONAL DATA ELEMENTS THAT
WE'VE FLAGGED. HOURS WORKED,
OCCUPATION REGION WORKED, AND
REGION, LIVE. ED LED THE
ASSESSMENT OF THE BASE WAGE FILE
SYSTEM TO REACH THESE NUMBERS.
THE SB 755 PLAN DOCUMENTS THE
SIGNIFICANT IT AND PROCESS
RELATED ADJUSTMENTS THAT WOULD
BE REQUIRED TO THE DATA INTAKE
FORMS, DATA INTAKE
INFRASTRUCTURE, AND THE EMPLOYER
RELATED SUPPORT AND TRAINING
THAT EDD DELIVERS. AS ED ALSO
LED A REVIEW OF LESSONS LEARNED
FROM OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
CONSIDERED OR ALREADY
IMPLEMENTED EXPANSIONS TO THE
BASE WAGE FILE. LESSONS LEARNED
INCLUDE UNDERTAKING THE BURDEN
UNDER STANDING THE BURDEN PLACED
ON EMPLOYERS TO ADAPT THEIR
PAYROLL SYSTEMS TO REVISE DATA
INTAKE REQUIREMENTS. PROVIDING
TECHNICAL SUPPORT TO EMPLOYERS
ON UNDERSTANDING OCCUPATION
RELATED DATA ENTRY, AND
INCORPORATING DATA QUALITY
ASSESSMENT AND REVIEW INTO DATA
ENTRY WORKFLOW. SO THESE WERE
NOTED AS VERY IMPORTANT FROM
OTHER STATES. ED BUILT THE TIME
AND FINANCIAL ESTIMATES AROUND A
NO PENALTIES APPROACH, MEANING
THERE WOULD BE NO PENALTIES TO
EMPLOYERS WHO ARE UNABLE TO
PROVIDE ANY OF THESE SPECIFIC
NEW DATA ELEMENTS IN THE SB 755
PLAN, ED'S ASSESSMENT OUTLINES A
PHASED APPROACH TO EXPANDING THE
SYSTEM AND PHASING IN LARGE AND
THEN SMALL EMPLOYERS. WITH
COMPLETION OF THE EXPANSION
POSSIBLE WITHIN FIVE YEARS OF
APPROPRIATION AND LEGISLACIÓN
THÀNH. THE REMAINING SET OF
ACTIVITIES RELATES TO THE
EXPANSION OF THE CAL SKILLS
SYSTEM. KWBW ESTIMATES 500,000
IN 1 TIME COST TO EXPAND THE
SECOND PHASE OF THE CAL SKILLS
EVALUATION ANALYSIS SO THAT IT
CAN INCLUDE CDBS PROGRAMS. THE
EVALUATION ANALYSIS WILL REMAIN
LIMITED REGARDING TRAINING
RELATED EMPLOYMENT AND REGIONAL
LIVING WAGE ANALYSIS. UNLESS THE
BASE WAGE FILE IS ENHANCED, KWBW
ESTIMATES IT WOULD REQUIRE
500,000 ANNUALLY FOR STAFF TIME
TO EXPAND THE CAL SKILLS DATA
INTAKE AND DASHBOARD SYSTEM IN
ORDER TO ADD THE KWBW PROGRAMS
AND ALIGN WITH THE EXPANDED
ANALYSIS ELEMENTS THAT ARE
DEFINED IN SB 755. WE ALSO
ESTIMATE 300,000 IN 1 TIME COST
TO INDEPENDENTLY ASSESS THE CAL
SKILLS SYSTEM. ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES. TO ASSESS ITS
CURRENT PLACEMENT WITHIN KWBW.
GIVEN THE POTENTIALLY EXPANDED
SCOPE AND EVOLVING ROLE OF KWBW
IN JOB TRAINING, PROGRAM DESIGN
AND IMPLEMENTATION, AND FINALLY
FOR THE EXPANDED ANALYSIS AND
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS, ED WOULD
REQUIRE AN ESTIMATED 150,000
ANNUALLY FOR STAFF TIME TO
CONDUCT EXPANDED BASE WAGE FILE
MERGING TO PARTICIPANT DATA
SYSTEMS AND ED NCDB ESTIMATE 85
TO 255,000 FOR ADDITIONAL STAFF.
TIME FOR THE EXPANDED REPORTING
REQUIREMENT. YES, THAT BRINGS ME
TO THE END. I HAVE TO SAY THAT
THE COST ESTIMATES FOR
IMPLEMENTATION SEEM INCREDIBLY
REASONABLE FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. HAVING SPENT A LOT
OF TIME ON IN BUDGETS OF 4 OR 6
YEARS ACTUALLY CHAIRING THAT
WHEN WE HAD ALL OF OUR OTHER IT
PROGRAMS MOVING AHEAD IN
CALIFORNIA, AND 25.4 MILLION
PROBABLY WAS, SOME COST OF SOME
STUDY ALONG THE WAY FOR ONE OF
THOSE, LET ME ASK A QUESTION. SO
HOW HOW DO YOU EVALUATE THOSE OF
YOU IN, IN, AT THE BOARD OR IN
THE AGENCY? HOW DO YOU EVALUATE
OVERALL THE TRAINING PROGRAMS
THAT ARE IN PLACE RIGHT NOW IN
THE STATE? IN OTHER WORDS,
QUALITY CONTROL. YOU HAVE DATA
POINTS THAT SHOW NUMBERS OF
PARTICIPANTS, CREDENTIAL WAS
AWARDED, AND YOU HAVE INCOME,
PRESUMABLY FROM A JOB OF SOME
KIND. SO WHEN YOU LOOK AND DO
YOU HAVE A PROGRAM, WHERE DO YOU
HAVE A PROCESS WHERE YOU
EVALUATE FROM A QUALITY
STANDPOINT, NOT JUST QUANTITY,
BUT FROM A QUALITY STANDPOINT,
TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT YOU WE
HAVE FUNDED, IS THAT A FAIR
QUESTION? I CAN JUMP UP WITH ONE
ANSWER. SO THERE ARE A FEW WAYS
IN WHICH WE CONDUCT PERFORMANCE
ANALYSIS AND EVALUATION. SO FOR
EXAMPLE, STANDARD WIOA
PERFORMANCE ANALYSIS REPORTING
MEETS, FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS FOR
KWBW. THERE IS AN INDEPENDENT
EVALUATION PROCESS. SO MANY OF
THE PROGRAMS THEY MAY NOT HAVE A
STANDARDIZED SET OF COMMON
METRICS AND PERFORMANCE ANALYSIS
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS, BUT AT
MOST OF THE CDB PROGRAMS HAVE AN
INDEPENDENT EVALUATION THAT IS
DESIGNED AND IMPLEMENTED
ALONGSIDE IT AND THEN EVENTUALLY
PUBLICLY PUBLISHED. WELL,
NOTWITHSTANDING WHAT WHAT DATA
ELEMENTS WE COLLECT CURRENTLY
COLLECT OR DO NOT COLLECT. SO IF
I'M A IF I OPERATE A TRAINING
PROGRAM IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND I'M GOING TO TRAIN, I DON'T
KNOW, WELDERS AND I GET A I'M
FUNDED BY THE AGENCY OR BY THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD TO
TRAIN WELDERS. AND I AT THE END
OF EACH YEAR, I TURN OUT, 100
INDIVIDUALS WITH A WELDER
CERTIFICATION. THAT'S REPORTED,
I ASSUME, AND THEN, OF COURSE,
YOU DO THE DATA COLLECTION ON
THE DATA POINTS. YOU DO COLLECT,
AND YOU FIND OUT THAT THESE
WELDERS HAVE AN AVERAGE ANNUAL
INCOME OF $15,000 PER YEAR. WE
DON'T KNOW WHETHER IT'S DOING
WELDING OR WHETHER IT'S A
BARISTA AND STARBUCKS OR
MCDONALD'S OR DOING SOMETHING
ELSE, MAYBE SOMETHING ELSE IN
CONSTRUCTION. I GATHER IF THAT'S
WHAT I TOLD YOU I WAS GOING TO
DO, THEN I GET A I GET A GOLD
STAR, AND I'M OKAY TO MOVE
FORWARD RIGHT? YEAH. I WOULD SAY
UNDER THE CURRENT SYSTEM, I MOVE
FORWARD. I CONTINUE, I SUBMIT MY
APPLICATION FOR FUNDING FOR THE
NEXT YEAR AND I'M FUNDED BECAUSE
I MEET THE PERFORMANCE METRICS
THAT ARE IN EXISTENCE TODAY.
RIGHT? YEAH. WHEN WE GATHER THE
DATA, WHICH INCLUDES THE PROGRAM
START DATE AND PROGRAM END DATE
AND, WHEN THE PARTICIPANTS GOT,
YOU KNOW, WHAT KIND OF TRAINING
THEY WENT THROUGH AND WHEN DID
THEY EXIT. AND ALSO SO, THE
DEMOGRAPHICS INFORMATION ABOUT,
THE WHOLE PARTICIPANTS, PLUS THE
BASE WAGE INFORMATION WE WILL
HAVE A CLEAR IDEA WHEN WE DO THE
ANALYSIS. WE HAVE A CLEAR IDEA
OF WHERE DID HE START AFTER
DURING THE, DURING THE PROGRAM,
IN OUR TRAINING PROCESS. HOW
MUCH WAS HIS EARNINGS? AND RIGHT
AFTER, WHEN HE'S DONE WITH THE
TRAINING, HOW MUCH? YOU KNOW, HE
STARTED EARNING RIGHT AFTER THE
PROGRAM OR RIGHT AFTER LIKE
SECOND QUARTER EXIT OF THE
PROGRAM. SO WE DO THAT
COMPARISON AND WE'LL, WE'LL,
WE'LL BE ABLE TO FIGURE OUT
WHETHER THE PROGRAM REALLY
WORKED AND THE TRAINING REALLY
GAVE HIM, THE PROPER OUTCOME FOR
THE, FOR THE PARTICIPANT. BUT IS
THAT REALLY TRUE? DOES THAT DOES
YOUR ANALYSIS TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
INCREASES IN THE IN THE MINIMUM
WAGE, FOR EXAMPLE, OR MARKET
CONDITIONS IN PARTICULAR REGIONS
WHICH DRIVE WAGES UP? YES I MEAN
THAT THAT IS A MISSING PIECE
HERE AND WHICH SB 755 IS GOING
TO ADD UP. WE ARE GOING TO WE
ARE GOING TO ADD, THAT IS I
WOULD SAY ANY, ANY ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION, ANY ADDITIONAL
DATA, WOULD BE, WOULD MAKE IT
MEANINGFUL FOR OUR AGGREGATES
AND OTHER, REPORTING WHICH WE
ARE PROVIDING, THE ADDITION OF
OCCUPATION OF TRAINING,
OCCUPATION OF EMPLOYMENT, THAT
ALONE GOES A LONG WAY. AND ALSO,
THE MEASURABLE SKILL GAIN RATE
AND HOW WAS WORKED PRIOR TO
PROGRAM ENTRY, HOW WAS WORKED
POST PROGRAM EXIT AND LIVING
CURRENT LIVING WAGE AND THE COST
OF LIVING FOR THAT, THE AREA THE
REGIONAL PLANNING UNIT WHERE
THEY ARE LOCATED. ALL THOSE CAN
GET, YOU KNOW, WE CAN WE CAN
CREATE MORE MEANINGFUL REPORT
WITH ALL THESE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THAT WE ARE GOING TO
COLLECT. I AGREE, I WAS JUST
TRYING TO I MEAN, IT SEEMS TO ME
WE'RE NOT WE DON'T KNOW WHETHER
WE'RE TAKING CREDIT FOR THINGS
THAT ARE OUTSIDE OF THE CONTROL
OF THE TRAINER AND THE TRAINING
PROGRAM OR NOT. AND THE QUESTION
IS, YOU KNOW, IS THAT THE IS
THAT THE PROPER PLACE FOR OUR
TRAINING DOLLARS OR SHOULD WE
SHIFT THEM SOMEPLACE ELSE? IF
YOU ONLY NEED TEN WELDERS AND
YOU'RE YOU'RE FUNDING 100 SLOTS
IN A TRAINING PROGRAM EVERY
YEAR, AND YOU ONLY CAN FILL TEN
OF THEM IN A PARTICULAR REGION,
THEN MAYBE WE'RE NOT DIRECTING
OUR TRAINING DOLLARS TO THE
RIGHT TRAINING PROGRAM. AM I
MAKING SENSE? THAT MAKES SENSE.
SO WHEN YOU DO YOUR ANALYSIS OF
TRAINING PROGRAMS, DO YOU DO YOU
EVER DO YOU HAVE A PROCESS BY
WHICH TRAINING PROGRAMS ARE
CANCELED BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
PRODUCTIVE? CURRENTLY, WE DON'T
DO THE COMPARISON OF THE PROGRAM
BY LOOKING AT WHICH PROGRAM
WORKS BETTER ON CERTAIN
GEOGRAPHICAL AREA THAT
COMPARISON IS NOT DONE IN CAL
SKILLS, SO WE REALLY NEED TO
WORK ON OUR LABOR, OUR LABOR
OUTCOME ANALYSIS HERE AND
WHETHER WE'RE REALLY IMPROVING
PEOPLE IN TERMS OF THEIR JOBS
AND CAREERS. RIGHT? YES WELL.
WELL, IS THERE A DO WE INSIST,
FOR EXAMPLE, THAT TRAINING
PROGRAMS THAT RECEIVE MONEY
REGARDLESS OF WHICH BUCKET IT
COMES OUT OF, PROVIDE
PARTICIPANTS? THIS IS WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IN IN SB 755,
PROVIDE PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS
WITH PERFORMANCE DATA ON HOW
THEY CAN EXPECT TO PERFORM ONCE
THEY COMPLETE THE TRAINING
PROGRAMS. DO WE DO THAT TODAY IN
SOME OTHER WAY? WE DO NOT KNOW,
AND THAT'S WHY IT'S INCLUDED AS
AN ADDITIONAL COST. THAT'S IN
THE SB 755 PLAN FOR ADDITIONAL
REPORTING. WELL, THEN SO THE
COST OF IMPLEMENTING 755, IF IT
TURNS OUT TO BE THIS COST
INCREASE ALL THE TIME, BUT LET'S
SAY 30, $31 MILLION FIRST YEAR
AND THEN ONGOING, 6 TO 10
MILLION YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER
YEAR. HAVE YOU PROJECTED DID YOU
PROJECT ANY SORT OF SAVINGS IN
IN THE KIND OF ANALYSIS OF
TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT WERE
CONTEMPLATING WITH SB 755, WHERE
WE ELIMINATE THE INEFFICIENT AND
INEFFECTIVE ONES AND SHIFT MONEY
EITHER BACK INTO THE STATE'S
COFFERS OR BACK TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, OR INTO OTHER
TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT ARE MORE
EFFECTIVE. CAN WE PROJECT? IT'S
A GOOD QUESTION, BUT THAT SORT
OF COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS WASN'T
A PART OF THE SB 755 PLAN, BUT I
THINK IT'S A GOOD QUESTION. ARE
WE ABLE TO DO IT WITH THE DATA
WE HAVE CURRENTLY? I MEAN,
ESSENTIALLY YOU NEED AN
ACCOUNTING OF FULL COSTS AND A
WAY OF ACCOUNTING FOR FULL
POTENTIAL BENEFITS FOR, FOR WHAT
YOU'RE ABLE TO ACHIEVE. AND I'M
NOT SURE YET HOW WE WOULD DO
THAT, BUT IT CERTAINLY I MEAN,
IS AN INTERESTING QUESTION.
WELL, I MEAN, IF YOU HAVE
TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT ARE
TRAINING PEOPLE FOR JOBS THAT
EITHER DON'T EXIST OR THEY'RE
TRAINING MORE PEOPLE FOR JOBS
THAN CURRENTLY EXIST, THAT HAS A
COST ELEMENT TO IT, DOESN'T IT?
IN TERMS OF THE TRAINING
DOLLARS, WE'RE PUTTING INTO THE
TRAINING PROGRAM? IT DOES. I
MEAN, ONE THING I WOULD MENTION
WITH ESPECIALLY THE SORT OF
EVALUATION ANALYSIS THAT WE'RE
WE'RE LOOKING AT HERE,
ESPECIALLY THE SORT OF RIGOROUS
CAUSAL IMPACT ANALYSIS THAT WAS
DONE BY CALIFORNIA POLICY LAB
FOR LOOKING AT PROGRAMS LIKE WE
WIOA TITLE ONE. THERE'S ALSO A
TIMING ISSUE. SOMETIMES AND THE
TIMING OF WHEN RESULTS COME OUT,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU WANT TO LOOK
AT THREE YEARS POST TRAINING,
YOU KNOW, WHEN THOSE RESULTS
COME OUT AND WHEN WE'RE MAKING
FUNDING DECISIONS AND SOMETIMES
HAVE DIFFERENT CYCLES. SO IT'S
JUST ALWAYS IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER, KIND OF THE, THE
DIFFERENT TIMELINES OF WHEN THE
RESULTS OF RIGOROUS EVALUATION
ANALYSIS, RIGOROUS PERFORMANCE
ANALYSIS ARE AVAILABLE AND WHEN
FUNDING DECISIONS ARE MADE FOR
DIFFERENT BUDGET CYCLES. IN
TERMS OF SOME OF THE DECISION
POINTS THAT YOU REFERENCED IN
THE REPORT FOR IMPLEMENTATION,
THE NO PENALTY VERSUS PENALTY
ISSUE, WHICH I THOUGHT WAS A
SIGNIFICANT ONE. BUT THE SYSTEM
CURRENTLY IS A NO PENALTY
SYSTEM, RIGHT. IN TERMS OF DATA
COLLECTION. SO CURRENTLY THE
SYSTEM IS NO PENALTY. AND IS IT
WORKING? ABSOLUTELY. COMPLIANCE
RATES, PEOPLE COMPLY WITH THE
DATA THAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
REPORT. NON COMPLIANCE IS
USUALLY WHEN A BUSINESS GETS
INTO FINANCIAL DIFFICULTIES AND
THEY STOP REPORTING ALTOGETHER
RATHER THAN STOP REPORTING DATA
NEED TO REPORT IN TERMS OF THE
DATA POINTS THAT ARE REFERENCED
IN SB 755 THE HOURS WORKED AND
THE OCCUPATIONAL CODE, AND THE
OTHER ELEMENTS LOCATION. DO YOU
ANTICIPATE ANY SIGNIFICANT
ISSUES WITH IMPLEMENTING THAT
PIECE AND OBTAINING THE DATA
FROM THE EMPLOYMENT COMMUNITY?
WE DO NOT. IT'S GOING TO TAKE
SIGNIFICANT MARKETING AND
OUTREACH, IT'S GOING TO TAKE
OUTREACH TO THE EMPLOYER
COMMUNITY. IT'S GOING TO TAKE
OUTREACH TO THE EMPLOYER PAYROLL
SERVICES COMMUNITY. IT'S ALSO
GOING TO TAKE OUTREACH TO THE
EMPLOYER PAYROLL PROGRAM
COMMUNITY TO GET THEM ON BOARD
WITH BEING ABLE TO COLLECT THE
NEW DATA ELEMENTS AND THE USE OF
THAT STANDARD OCCUPATIONAL
CLASSIFICATION. THAT'S WHAT IT'S
CALLED, RIGHT? SOC CODING, SOC
CODE, IS THAT GOING TO BE
DIFFICULT? I THINK THE STATES
THAT WE'VE LEARNED FROM FOUND
THAT THAT WAS THE MOST
DIFFICULT, ITEM TO COLLECT. AND
THEY HAVE ADDED ADDITIONAL STAFF
RESOURCES TO ASSIST THE EMPLOYER
COMMUNITY, WHICH WE WOULD PLAN
TO DO IN. BUT THAT'S SORT OF A
START UP, BECAUSE IF YOU'RE A
BUSINESS ONCE YOU FIGURE OUT
WHAT YOUR OCCUPATIONAL
CLASSIFICATIONS ARE, THEN YOU
HAVE IT, THEN YOU HAVE IT. SO
IT'S PART OF THE IT'S PART OF
THE RAMP UP TO GET THE EMPLOYER
COMMUNITY ON BOARD. AND CHAMBERS
OF COMMERCE CAN HELP DISSEMINATE
INFORMATION ABOUT THAT. I ASSUME
THE ONLY ONGOING THING THAT WE
HAVE IS WE HAVE EMPLOYERS THAT
GO OUT OF BUSINESS ALL THE TIME,
AND THEN WE HAVE NEW EMPLOYERS
EVERY YEAR. SO IN THEORY, WE
WOULD BE EDUCATING THE NEW
EMPLOYERS AS THEY COME INTO NEW
BUSINESSES, AS THEY HIRE
EMPLOYEES. AND I ASSUME THAT,
WHILE IT'S NOT TRUE UNIFORMLY
VÆ, WITHIN INDUSTRIES, THERE ARE
BATCHES OF OCCUPATIONAL
CLASSIFICATIONS THAT I WOULD
ASSUME WOULD BE THE SAME, THAT'S
POSSIBLE, BUT I'M NOT SURE. AND
I HAVEN'T LOOKED AT THE SOC LIST
TO SEE WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE, BY
BY TYPE OF INDUSTRY. YEAH, I
HAVE NOT REFERRED TO THE SOC
LIST EITHER. SO IN THE STATES
THAT ARE FIRST OF ALL, WHEN I
WAS LOOKING AT THE VARIOUS
REPORTS THAT, EXIST ON THIS
EFFORT NATIONALLY AND BY STATE,
LOOKS LIKE THIS WHOLE PROCESS IS
SORT OF IN ITS INFANCY ACROSS
THE NATION. SOME STATES ARE IN
PLANNING, PRE-PLANNING, WHATEVER
THAT MEANS. WERE YOU ABLE WHEN
YOU DID YOUR SURVEY TO DETERMINE
HOW OTHER STATES ARE FUNDING
THIS? NUMBER ONE, SO ALL OF THE
STATES THAT WE TALKED TO
INDICATED IT CAME FROM STATE
FUNDING SOURCES. WHICH GIVEN
YOUR ESTIMATE, WE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO DO, PERHAPS NOT THIS YEAR,
BUT ON YOUR TIMELINE, WE OUGHT
TO BE ABLE TO COME UP WITH $25
MILLION OUT OF OUR BUDGET TO
HELP YOU PROVIDE DATA AND MAKE
SURE OUR TRAINING PROGRAMS ARE
MORE EFFICIENT. LET'S SEE
.
IF WE WERE TO DO THIS, SB 755
AND WE HAD THE MONEY TOMORROW
AND WE COULD START IMPLEMENTING
IT, AND YOU PUT THE PLAN IN
PLACE, HOW WOULD YOU USE THIS?
THESE DATA POINTS TO CHANGE THE
WAY WE OPERATE. WE DESIGN AND
OPERATE OUR WORKFORCE TRAINING
PROGRAMS. NOW WE. THIS IS
OUTCOME DATA. WHAT WOULD YOU DO?
WHAT WOULD YOU DO THAT YOU'RE
NOT DOING TODAY WITH RESPECT TO
THE WAY WE SPEND MONEY, THE WAY
WE ADJUST, THE WAY WE SPEND
MONEY AND THE TRAINING PROGRAMS
THAT ARE OUT THERE IN TERMS OF
HOW WE EVALUATE THEM. IS THAT A
FAIR QUESTION? NOT NOT AN EASY
QUESTION. I MEAN, LIKE FOR ME,
FOR EXAMPLE, ON THE
ADMINISTRATIVE SIDE, THIS WOULD
RESULT IN NEW DATA ELEMENTS THAT
WE THINK WE COULD ABSORB WITHIN
THE CAL JOB SYSTEM AND SO ON. SO
THAT'S JUST ONE, YOU KNOW, FIRST
EASY STEP, YOU KNOW, IN THIS
COMPLEX THING. WELL, WELL LET ME
DO YOU DO WE THINK THAT IF WE
HAVE THESE DATA POINTS AND WE
PUT THEM IN PLAY TOMORROW AND
SIX MONTHS FROM TOMORROW, WE ALL
GATHER HERE AT THE WELL AND HAVE
A CONVERSATION. DO WE THINK THAT
THE DATA IS GOING TO SHOW THAT
UNIFORM. OUR TRAINING PROGRAMS
ARE TRAINING INDIVIDUALS FOR
JOBS THAT EXIST TODAY, THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS SECURE THOSE JOBS,
THAT THEY'RE REGIONALLY LIVING
WAGE POSITIONS, AND THAT THE
POSITIONS SHOW A CAREER PATH
TOWARDS SOMETHING ELSE. I MEAN,
IT'S A FAIR QUESTION, AND I
THINK THIS IS WHY YOU SEE BIG
COMMITMENTS FOR PERFORMANCE
ANALYSIS AND EVALUATION WITH
EVEN THE DATA WE HAVE. AND I
THINK IT'S HOW DO WE MAKE THE
BEST DECISIONS WE HAVE WITH THE
INFORMATION WE HAVE ABOUT THE
PROGRAMS. AND I THINK THE DATA
ELEMENTS THAT ARE SUGGESTED IN
SB 755 JUST GIVE MORE
INFORMATION, PARTICULARLY AROUND
TRAINING RELATED EMPLOYMENT, BUT
I THINK ALSO RECOGNIZING IN IN
THE CYCLE OF DECISION MAKING,
HAVING MORE DATA AND MORE
EVIDENCE AVAILABLE IS VERY
HELPFUL AT EVERY POINT IN TIME.
WHETHER IT INFORMS THAT PROGRAM,
OF, YOU KNOW, SCALE UP OR AN
ADJUSTMENT TO IT OR A NEW
PROGRAM. RIGHT. AND SO I THINK
THE CYCLE OF EVIDENCE BASED
POLICY MAKING IS SOMETHING WE'RE
VERY MUCH INTERESTED IN. AND I'M
NOT BEING CRITICAL BY MY
QUESTIONS. I'M VERY MUCH
APPRECIATIVE OF THE TIME AND
EFFORT THAT WENT INTO PREPARING
THE REPORT VERY THOUGHTFUL
REPORT, VERY DETAILED ANALYSIS,
MORE SO THAN MY BRAIN CAN
POSSIBLY PROCESS THIS. BUT I DO
RECOGNIZE EXCELLENT WORK WHEN I
SEE IT, AND I THINK THIS IS
CERTAINLY AN EFFORT THAT NEEDS
TO CONTINUE FOR HOWEVER LONG IT
TAKES TO IMPLEMENT, BECAUSE
WHETHER IT'S, $2 BILLION DOLLARS
AND A COUPLE PROGRAMS, A BIG
PROGRAMS, LARGELY FROM THE FEDS,
PLUS AN UNKNOWN AMOUNT OF STATE
GENERAL FUND MONEY, WHICH, YOU
KNOW, MAYBE THAT'S ANOTHER
BILLION DOLLARS OVER A PERIOD OF
TIME. NOW WE'RE TALKING REAL
MONEY AT, AT, YOU KNOW, 2 TO $3
BILLION. I THINK WE REALLY OWE,
EVERYONE, INCLUDING THE TRAINING
PARTICIPANTS, A THOUGHTFUL AND
THOROUGH, THOROUGH ANALYSIS TO
MAKE SURE THAT PARTICIPANTS ARE
TOLD UP FRONT WHAT THE JOB
EXPECTATIONS ARE AND THESE
PROGRAMS AND WHAT THEY CAN
EXPECT TO SEE LONG TERM IN TERMS
OF CAREER GROWTH AND WAGES. SO
I'LL DEPEND ON YOU ALL TO, TO
HELP IMPLEMENT THAT SINCE, I
UNFORTUNATELY WON'T BE AROUND TO
SEE THE CONCLUSION SUCCESSFUL
CONCLUSION, I HOPE, OF THIS, DID
I THINK YOU TOLD ME AND ANSWERED
THIS QUESTION? DO YOU ANTICIPATE
RATE, THAT WE'LL BE ABLE TO FIND
ANY FEDERAL FUNDING TO HELP WITH
THIS? I WOULD SAY AS FAR AS WE Þ
DOLLARS, THERE'S A, HOW WOULD
YOU SAY IT'S VERY, THERE'S A
WHOLE LOT OF PRIORITIES ON THAT
FUNDING. AND THAT WAS TOP OF
MIND THROUGHOUT. AND THAT'S WHY
WE REQUESTED STATE GENERAL FUNDS
MOVING FORWARD IN THIS BUDGET
CLIMATE, THERE'S GOING TO BE A
LOT OF PRIORITIES, A LOT OF HIGH
PRIORITY INITIATIVES THAT WE'RE
CURRENTLY FUNDING AND WISH TO
CONTINUE, LIKE SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS THAT TARGET THE
DISABLED COMMUNITY, BE IT THE
FARMWORKERS AND WHAT HAVE YOU.
SO, THOSE ARE OBVIOUSLY VERY
IMPORTANT TO MY COLLEAGUES AND
I. SO I'M NOT SUGGESTING THAT WE
START CHOPPING AWAY AT PROGRAMS
TO DO THIS. I WAS JUST CURIOUS
AS TO WHETHER YOU THOUGHT THERE
WERE ANY, ANY OTHER BUCKETS OF
MONEY COMING OUT OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, SINCE THEY CAN PRINT
IT, THAT WE HAVEN'T TAPPED?
YEAH. I MEAN, LIKE I SAID
EARLIER, I'M HOPING WITH THIS
NATIONAL INTEREST AND THIS
ENHANCED DATA, THAT ONE DAY WE
WILL SEE SOME FEDERAL FUNDING
FOR THIS TYPE OF WORK, BUT AT
THIS JUNCTURE, NOT ON THE
HORIZON. OKAY. WELL, LET ME SEE
IF MY COLLEAGUE HAS ANY
QUESTIONS. I, I DO APPRECIATE
YOUR HARD WORK, AND THIS IS A
MAJOR PROJECT. AND I HOPE IT
CONTINUES AND YOU WILL MAKE A
HUGE DIFFERENCE IN THIS, I
THINK, IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, IN WORKFORCE
TRAINING, IF WE'RE ABLE TO GET A
HANDLE ON WHERE THE MONEY GOES,
HOW IT'S BEING SPENT, HOW IT CAN
BE SPENT MORE EFFECTIVELY, AND
YOU'RE GOING TO HELP A WHOLE TON
OF WORKERS OUT THERE WHO ARE
SIMPLY TRYING TO PUT BREAD ON
THE TABLE. SO THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. LET'S CALL UP OUR
SECOND PANEL TO TALK ABOUT THE
VALUE OF THESE NEW DATA POINTS
AND WHAT WE CAN POSSIBLY DO WITH
INFORMATION ONCE WE'RE ABLE TO
RECEIVE IT
.
GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. DRIVING OUT HERE,
LET ME HAVE YOU INTRODUCE
YOURSELVES. STARTING TO MY LEFT.
YOUR RIGHT. MA'AM OH, SORRY,
GOOD MORNING, I'M SARAH BOWEN,
I'M VICE PRESIDENT AT PICK THE
PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA, WHERE I DIRECT OUR
NEW ECONOMIC POLICY CENTER.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US, SIR.
I'M JESSE ROTHSTEIN. I'M THE
KAMAL P FRIESEN PROFESSOR OF
ECONOMICS AND PUBLIC POLICY AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA,
BERKELEY, WHERE I'M ALSO THE
FACULTY DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA POLICY LAB. THANK YOU
BOTH. FEEL FREE TO START. WE
WANTS TO BE FIRST, FLIP A COIN.
WHAT DO YOU I GUESS I WAS THE
FIRST ON THE PROGRAM, SO I
ASSUMED ME, BUT OKAY. OKAY. GOOD
MORNING. THANK YOU FOR HAVING
FOR GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK WITH YOU TODAY. I'M I'VE IN
ADDITION TO MY CURRENT ROLE,
I'VE SERVED IN A VARIETY OF
STAFF ADVISORY AND CONSULTING
ROLES AT THE STATE AND FEDERAL
LEVEL, ADVISING PUBLIC AGENCIES
ABOUT THE COLLECTION, ANALYSIS
AND INTERPRETATION OF LABOR
MARKET DATA. AND I'LL BE DRAWING
ON THAT EXPERIENCE IN TALKING
TODAY. LET ME START WITH THE
BOTTOM LINE. ENHANCED THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BASE WAGE
FILE BY COLLECTING ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ON HOURS WORKED,
OCCUPATION, AND THE LOCATION OF
WORK AS PLANNED UNDER SB 755 HAS
CLEAR BENEFITS FOR CALIFORNIA
WORKERS, EMPLOYERS AND THE STATE
AS A WHOLE. IT WOULD GREATLY
EXPAND OUR UNDERSTANDING OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR MARKET AND HELP
POLICYMAKERS NAVIGATE THE STATE
THROUGH BETTER WORKFORCE, LABOR
MARKET, SOCIAL SAFETY, NET
EDUCATION, AND OTHER POLICIES.
FOR DECADES, THE BASE WAGE FILE
HAS PLAYED AN ESSENTIAL ROLE IN
HELPING POLICYMAKERS ASSESS HOW
WELL OUR TAXPAYER FUNDED
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
ARE SERVING WORKING CALIFORNIANS
BY PROVIDING TIMELY INFORMATION
ABOUT QUARTERLY EMPLOYMENT AND
EARNINGS FOR ALL WORKERS IN THE
STATE, THE BASE WAGE FILE HAS
SERVED AS THE BACKBONE OF
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAM
EVALUATION IN CALIFORNIA AND
NATIONALLY. DATA. THIS
COMPREHENSIVE AND THIS
FOUNDATIONAL TO EMPLOYMENT
POLICY WOULD BE NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO OBTAIN FROM OTHER
SOURCES. HOWEVER, OUR ABILITY TO
USE THE BASE WAGE FILE TO
SUPPORT WORKFORCE TRAINING
PROGRAMS IS LIMITED BY THE
COARSENESS OF THE INFORMATION IT
CONTAINS, AS WE CAN MEASURE
WHETHER INDIVIDUALS ARE EMPLOYED
AND HOW MUCH THEY EARN IN A
QUARTER. BUT THERE ARE OTHER
IMPORTANT METRICS, SUCH AS
WHETHER A WORKER IS WORKING FULL
TIME, WHETHER SHE'S FOUND A JOB
IN THE OCCUPATION FOR WHICH
SHE'S TRAINED, AND WHETHER SHE'S
EARNING A LIVING WAGE THAT WE
CANNOT MEASURE IN CURRENT DATA.
THE CALIFORNIA POLICY LAB, WHICH
I DIRECT, WORKED, WORKED WITH
THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD IN 2022 TO
STUDY WHETHER PARTICIPATION IN
THE STATE'S WORKFORCE TRAINING
PROGRAMS LED TO BETTER
EMPLOYMENT AND EARNINGS
OUTCOMES. THIS WAS THE CAL
SKILLS EVALUATION THAT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT TODAY. THIS WAS
MADE POSSIBLE BY THE INTEGRATION
OF TRAINING PROGRAM DATA WITH
THE BASE WAGE FILE UNDER CAL
SKILLS, DEVELOPED UNDER ASSEMBLY
BILL 2148 AND 1336. WE FOUND
THAT MANY OF THE TRAINING
PROGRAMS INDEED RAISED
PARTICIPANTS EMPLOYMENT AND
EARNINGS BY A SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT
, ALTHOUGH THE IMPACTS VARIED.
IMPORTANTLY ACROSS PROGRAMS.
UNFORTUNATELY, WITH THE LIMITED
OUTCOMES WE HAD AVAILABLE, WE
COULDN'T DO MUCH TO UNDERSTAND
WHY THEY VARIED SO MUCH. WE
WOULD HAVE LIKED TO MEASURE
WHETHER WORKERS WERE FULL TIME
OR PART TIME, WHETHER THEY WERE
WORKING IN THE OCCUPATIONS FOR
WHICH THEY HAD TRAINED. AS YOU
DISCUSSED EARLIER, SENATOR ROTH,
AND WHETHER THEY WERE EARNING
LIVING WAGES WITH THE PROPOSED
EXPANSION OF THE BASE WAGE FILE
TO INCLUDE OCCUPATION HOURS AND
LOCATION INFORMATION, WE'D BE
ABLE TO DO ALL OF THESE. THIS
WOULD GENERATE THE KIND OF
EVIDENCE THAT WE NEED TO BETTER
ALIGN CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE
TRAINING PROGRAMS WITH THE NEEDS
OF OUR ECONOMY. THE DISCUSSION
TODAY THUS FAR HAS FOCUSED
MOSTLY ON THE VALUE OF AN
ENHANCED BASE WAGE FILE FOR
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAMS, BUT
THE POTENTIAL BENEFITS GO WELL
BEYOND WORKFORCE PROGRAMS. SO
LET ME TALK ABOUT A FEW OF THOSE
. FIRST, THE STATE IS NOW MAKING
A LARGE INVESTMENT IN THE CRADLE
TO CAREER DATA SYSTEM, WHICH
WILL CONNECT INFORMATION ON K-12
AND POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION
WITH THE BASE WAGE FILE. THIS
WILL HAVE MANY BENEFITS FOR
EVIDENCE BASED PLANNING AND
DECISION MAKING, AS ONE EXAMPLE,
IT WILL ENABLE COLLEGES TO
MEASURE THE POST-GRADUATION
EMPLOYMENT AND EARNINGS OF THEIR
STUDENTS, AND THUS TO ASSESS
WHICH PROGRAMS ARE DELIVERING
THE INSTRUCTION STUDENTS NEED TO
ACHIEVE ECONOMIC SUCCESS. BUT
THIS WORK IS BADLY HAMPERED BY
THE INABILITY TO TELL WHETHER
LOW EARNINGS REFLECT PART TIME
WORK. PARTIAL QUARTER WORK OR
LOW HOURLY WAGES, AND ENHANCED
BASE WAGE FILE WOULD PERMIT SUCH
A DISTINCTION. IT WOULD ALSO
HELP US UNDERSTAND WHETHER
STUDENTS ARE WORKING IN THEIR
FIELD OF STUDY. ANOTHER KEY
METRIC FOR STUDENT SUCCESS.
SECOND, THE NEW DATA WOULD
PERMIT THE PROVISION OF MUCH
BETTER LABOR MARKET INFORMATION
FOR EMPLOYERS, WORKERS AND
PLANNERS. AS A RESULT OF THE
COVID 19 PANDEMIC AND ONGOING
TECHNOLOGICAL CHANGE, WE'RE
SEEING STRUCTURAL SHIFTS IN THE
STATE'S ECONOMY WITH SOMETIMES
SEVERE WORKER SHORTAGES IN
CRITICAL FIELDS. IMAGINE BEING
ABLE TO IDENTIFY HOTSPOTS FOR
HIGH WAGE JOB OPPORTUNITIES IN A
PARTICULAR OCCUPATION. WE COULD
HELP DIRECT JOB SEEKERS WITH THE
APPROPRIATE SKILLS AND HELP
BUSINESSES FILL THEIR CRITICAL
JOBS. THIRD, THE NEW DATA WOULD
BE USEFUL FOR IDENTIFYING
VIOLATIONS OF MINIMUM WAGE,
OVERTIME, AND WORKER
CLASSIFICATION RULES, AND THUS
FOR TARGETING ENFORCEMENT AND
COMPLIANCE EFFORTS. WHEN SOME
EFFORTS IGNORE ONES. WHEN SOME
EMPLOYERS IGNORE THE RULES, THEY
CAN OBTAIN AN UNDESERVED
ADVANTAGE OVER OTHER EMPLOYERS
WHO ARE TRYING TO COMPETE
FAIRLY. IMPROVING COMPLIANCE IN
THESE AREAS WILL MEAN MORE
WORKERS EARNING LIVING WAGES AND
A MORE LEVEL PLAYING FIELD.
FOURTH, DATA ON THE LOCATION OF
WORK WILL BE ENORMOUSLY VALUABLE
FOR LOCAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
PLANNING, INCLUDING ADJUSTMENT
ASSISTANCE. WHERE IS EMPLOYMENT
GROWING OR SHRINKING? WHERE ARE
WE GOING TO NEED TO RELIEVE
TRANSIT BOTTLENECKS OR BUILD
MORE HOUSING TO ENABLE CONTINUED
ECONOMIC GROWTH? WHERE MIGHT WE
NEED TO PROVIDE ADJUSTMENT
ASSISTANCE FOR WORKERS FACING
DECLINING DEMAND FOR THEIR
OCCUPATIONS? WHERE MIGHT THERE
BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO ATTRACT A
NEW EMPLOYER TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF A SKILLED LABOR POOL THAT HAS
BEEN FREED UP BY CHANGES IN
EMPLOYMENT IN A PREVIOUS LOCAL
TENT POLE? EMPLOYER I'VE SPENT
OVER 25 YEARS DOING RESEARCH ON
PUBLIC POLICY AND LABOR
ECONOMICS, AND OVER A DECADE
WORKING WITH POLICYMAKERS TO
MAKE BETTER USE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE DATA IN SERVICE
OF WORKERS, BUSINESSES AND THE
OVERALL ECONOMY. MY PERSPECTIVE
IS SUPPORTED BY DECADES OF
RESEARCH THAT UNAMBIGUOUSLY
SPEAKS TO THE VALUE OF ENHANCING
BASE WAGE INFORMATION WITH THE
THREE DATA VARIABLES I DESCRIBED
TODAY, MY MOST RECENT STUDY USES
CENSUS BUREAU DATA WITH JOB
LOCATIONS TO STUDY MISMATCHES
BETWEEN WORKER RESIDENTIAL
LOCATIONS AND LOCATIONS OF JOBS,
FOCUSING ON RUST BELT CITIES
WHERE WE COULD GET DATA FROM THE
CENSUS BUREAU. THIS IS EXACTLY
THE KIND OF RESEARCH ON JOB
DESERTS THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO DO FOR CALIFORNIA, AND
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO DO WITH AN
ENHANCED BASE WAGE FILE BY
IMPROVING OUR RESEARCH AND
ANALYTIC CAPABILITIES, THE STATE
CAN SPEND TAX DATA, TAXPAYER
DOLLARS FOR WORKFORCE TRAINING
AND EDUCATION MORE EFFICIENTLY,
REDUCE COSTLY FRICTIONS, AND
EXTENDED AND EXTENDED
UNEMPLOYMENT DRIVEN BY CHANGES
IN LOCAL LABOR MARKETS. BETTER
PLAN FOR CHANGING LABOR MARKET
NEEDS AND HELP KEEP THE STATE'S
ECONOMY RUNNING SMOOTHLY. LET ME
SUMMARIZE AND WRAP UP
INFORMATION ON WORKERS HOURS AND
OCCUPATIONS WILL ALLOW US TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE EFFECTS OF
CHANGES IN THE LABOR MARKET ON
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY, AND TO
FURTHER IMPROVE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR EDUCATION
AND TRAINING SYSTEM. TO PREPARE
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE FOR THE
21ST CENTURY. INFORMATION ON
LOCATION OF WORK WILL ALLOW US
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND WHO IS
BEING MOST AFFECTED BY CHANGES
IN THE LABOR MARKET, AND HOW WE
MIGHT PLAN FOR SHIFTING ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS. WE KNOW THAT
COLLECTING THIS INFORMATION IS
ACHIEVABLE AND COST EFFECTIVE
BECAUSE OTHER STATES HAVE DONE
IT. WITHOUT THIS INFORMATION,
OUR EDUCATION, WORKFORCE
TRAINING AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PLANNERS WILL BE
HALF BLIND, UNABLE TO
EFFICIENTLY ADDRESS NEWFOUND
CHALLENGES AND THE CHANGING
NATURE OF WORK. GIVEN THE
STAGGERING IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC ON THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
MARKET, IN PARTICULAR ON JOBS
FOR LOWER AND MIDDLE INCOME
WORKERS AND CONCERNS ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF WORK, I THINK THESE
ENHANCEMENTS TO THE CALIFORNIA'S
TÚI BASE WAGE FILE ARE IMPORTANT
AND URGENT. SB 755 STARTED THE
BALL ROLLING, AND I APPLAUD ED
AND THE LABOR AGENCY FOR THEIR
WORK IN FIGURING OUT HOW IT
COULD BE IMPLEMENTED. AND I HOPE
THAT I'VE GIVEN YOU AN IDEA OF
THE BENEFITS THAT THIS WOULD
BRING TO THE STATE AND ITS LABOR
MARKET. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW, I'M SORT OF I HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CHAIR A BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE DEALING WITH
EDUCATION FINANCE, WHICH IS A
PRETTY LARGE PORTION OF OUR
BUDGET, ABOUT 40% FOR A COUPLE
OF YEARS. AND I WAS TROUBLED BY
IN THE HIGHER EDUCATION FIELD IN
PARTICULAR. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TELLING PARTICIPANTS IN OUR
TRAINING PROGRAMS WHAT THE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE AND TRY TO
LINK UP JOB TRAINING WITH ACTUAL
JOBS THAT EXIST. WE DON'T DO
THAT VERY WELL. AT LEAST WE
HAVEN'T IN MY VIEW, IN HIGHER
EDUCATION, WHAT'S THE VALUE OF A
SOCIOLOGY DEGREE AND WHAT CAN
YOU DO WITH THAT? AN
UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE. SO I'M
FASCINATED AT THE AT THE
POSSIBILITY THAT ON THE CRADLE
TO CAREER, DASHBOARD, THE
GOVERNOR'S DASHBOARD THAT WE
COULD PERHAPS LINK UP AND BE
ABLE TO TELL PEOPLE WHAT'S OUT
THERE FOR THEM IF, WHEN THEY
ENTER THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA FACILITY, IF THEY
CHOOSE A PARTICULAR SUBJECT
MATTER, WHAT IS OUT THERE OR IS
NOT OUT THERE FOR THEM AT THE
END OF THAT PROCESS? AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT, SIR, IS IT NOT? YES. THAT
IS I THINK THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
THAT RIGHT NOW THERE'S BEEN WORK
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS ON TRYING
TO DOCUMENT AVERAGE EARNINGS OF
PEOPLE IN VARIOUS MAJORS, BUT
THAT'S ABOUT ALL THAT WE KNOW
THUS FAR. AND WE WILL BE ABLE TO
TELL BECAUSE IT'S A TRAINING
PROGRAM AND THERE WILL BE
REPORTS ON OCCUPATION ONCE THE
PERSON EXITS THE TRAINING
PROGRAM AND WAGES EARNED AND
EARNED, NOT ONLY IMMEDIATELY,
BUT OVER TIME. EXACTLY. IT'D BE
POSSIBLE TO MEASURE WHAT
OCCUPATIONS PEOPLE WITH
SOCIOLOGY MAJORS, FOR EXAMPLE,
ARE GOING INTO WHICH OCCUPATIONS
ARE LEADING TO HIGH EARNINGS OR
TO HIGH EARNINGS GROWTH. THAT
COULD HAVE AN INTERESTING RESULT
OR IMPACT, BUT I GUESS WE'LL
SEE. HOT SPOTS FOR JOB
OPPORTUNITIES. HOW DOES HOW DOES
THAT WORK IN THE CONTEXT OF WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WITH SENATE
BILL 755, HOW HOW WOULD WE
IDENTIFY HOT SPOTS, GIVEN THE
DATA THAT WE'RE ASKING, DATA
POINTS THAT WE'RE ASKING BE
REPORTED? JUST AS AN EXAMPLE, WE
COULD WE WOULD BE ABLE TO SEE,
FOR EXAMPLE, THAT THERE HAD BEEN
GROWTH IN THE NUMBER OF WELDERS
EMPLOYED IN A PARTICULAR COUNTY
OVER, OVER A PERIOD, AND THAT
PERHAPS THAT GROWTH WAS
OUTSTRIPPING THE EXISTING
TRAINING CAPACITY FOR THAT
FIELD. THAT MIGHT HELP US TO
IDENTIFY PLACES WHERE THERE'S A
NEED FOR MORE TRAINING CAPACITY,
OR VICE VERSA, OR VICE VERSA.
EXACTLY WHICH THOSE ARE THE
STORIES THAT TEND TO HIT THE
NEWSPAPERS. YES. AND I'M CURIOUS
WITH RESPECT TO, WORKPLACE OR
LABOR LAW ENFORCEMENT IN THE
WORKPLACE, HOW DOES THIS I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND HOW THESE
DATA POINTS WOULD HELP WITH
THAT. WELL, YOU WOULDN'T WANT TO
TAKE THE ONE OF THE ONE OF THE
THINGS YOU'D BE ABLE TO DO WITH
THE BASE WAGE FILE IS DIVIDE
SOMEBODY'S QUARTERLY EARNINGS BY
THEIR NUMBER OF HOURS, AND THAT
GIVES YOU THEIR HOURLY WAGE. I
THINK THERE ARE LOTS OF REASONS
WHY YOU WOULDN'T WANT TO USE
THAT AS GOSPEL, BUT IT CAN BE A
GOOD INDICATOR OF SITUATIONS
WHERE PEOPLE MAY BE MAYBE BEING
PAID LESS THAN, THAN THE LAW
WOULD REQUIRE, AND MAYBE IS A IS
A AREA WHERE YOU MIGHT WANT TO
LOOK FURTHER. THAT'S TRUE. I
MEAN, IF THE IF THE DATA POINT
IS HOURS WORKED BY DAYS AND
WEEKS, YOU WOULD BE ABLE TO TAKE
A LOOK AT OVERTIME COMPLIANCE.
OVERTIME WOULD BE A LITTLE BIT
TRICKY UNLESS BECAUSE BECAUSE
WHAT YOU WOULD WHAT I BELIEVE
YOU WOULD GET UNDER SB 755 IS
THE NUMBER OF HOURS IN THE
QUARTER. SO KNOWING HOW BROKEN
DOWN BY DAYS AND WEEKS THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING. YEAH. AND SO BUT
THERE WOULD BE PATTERNS THAT
MIGHT BE SUGGESTIVE OF WORKERS
WHO ARE WORKING A LOT OF
OVERTIME OR WHO ARE WORKING FOR
LESS THAN THE MINIMUM WAGE. AND
THOSE THAT CAN BE THE BEGINNING
OF A FURTHER INVESTIGATION. IT
WOULDN'T BE THE END OF IT,
RIGHT? WE DIDN'T GET MORE. WE
WERE NOT MORE SPECIFIC IN 755.
THERE ARE APPARENTLY SOME STATES
THAT ARE TAKING A LOOK AT DAYS
AND HOURS BY DAYS AND WEEKS,
WHICH COULD PROVIDE EVEN MORE
INFORMATION IF ONE WANTED TO
SPEND THE TIME AND GO TO THE
EFFORT TO COLLECT IT. HOW WOULD,
HOW WOULD THIS DATA HAVE HELPED,
IF AT ALL, DURING THE PANDEMIC?
IS THAT A FAIR QUESTION? IT IS.
SO I WAS ONE OF SEVERAL HUNDRED
RESEARCH TEAMS WHO WERE ALL
RACING TO TRY TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
WAS GOING ON WITH THE LABOR
MARKET IN THE PANDEMIC. THE WORK
THAT I DID, WE WERE REALLY
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHICH JOBS
WERE GOING AWAY AND WE RELIED ON
WHAT WE CALLED A CONVENIENCE
SAMPLE. WE FOUND A PAYROLL
PROCESSOR THAT HAPPENED TO HAVE
DATA THAT WE COULD GET IN A
FAIRLY SHORT, FAIRLY QUICK
TURNAROUND THAT WE COULD
IDENTIFY WHICH WORKERS JOBS WENT
AWAY. AND WE WERE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY THE NATURE OF THE
EMPLOYER, HOW MUCH PREVIOUS
ATTACHMENT THE WORKER HAD HAD
THEIR THEIR HOURS, BUT WE
COULDN'T SEE THEIR OCCUPATION
EVEN IN THOSE DATA. I THINK IF
WE'D UNDERSTOOD WHICH
OCCUPATIONS THE JOBS HAD
STOPPED, YOU KNOW, YOU KNOW, BY
THE THIRD QUARTER OF 2020 THAT
WOULD HAVE DONE A LOT OF THAT
HELPED US A LOT IN PLANNING FOR
HOW DO WE BRING PEOPLE BACK TO
WORK? BECAUSE WHAT WE
CONTEMPLATE WITH SB 755 IS A
PERIODIC, PICTURE, EXACTLY, OF
CAREER PROGRESSION, OCCUPATIONS,
WAGE INCREASES OR NOT DIFFERENT
OCCUPATION, NO WAGE INCREASE. SO
SO, EVENTS LIKE A PANDEMIC OR
SOMETHING ELSE, LIKE A GREAT
RECESSION WOULD GIVE US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE WHERE PEOPLE
ARE AT A PARTICULAR POINT IN
TIME. RIGHT? RIGHT. AS WE BEGAN
TO COME OUT OF THE PANDEMIC, WE
SAW THAT THERE WERE LARGE
SECTORS WHERE EMPLOYERS WERE
HAVING TROUBLE FINDING WORKERS.
WE KNEW THERE WERE A LOT OF
WORKERS WHO HAD LOST THEIR JOBS
DURING THE PANDEMIC. IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE TO USE THE
BASE WAGE FILE TO TRY TO SEE HOW
MANY WORKERS WERE TRANSITIONING
FROM THE OLD JOBS INTO THESE NEW
HIGH DEMAND JOBS, AND THAT'S
WITHOUT OCCUPATION. IT'S MUCH,
MUCH HARDER TO BE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT ALL YOU CAN SEE
IS INDUSTRY, AND YOU DON'T
REALLY KNOW WHETHER THE JANITOR,
YOU KNOW, FOR EXAMPLE, THE
JANITORS MAY HAVE LOST JOBS IN
ONE INDUSTRY BUT BE PERFECTLY
SUITED TO WORK AS JANITORS IN
ANOTHER INDUSTRY. BUT YOU CAN'T
TELL THAT IF ALL YOU CAN SEE IS
THE INDUSTRY OF EMPLOYMENT AND
NOT THE OCCUPATION. AND I THINK
I BELIEVE EARLIER YOU MENTIONED
SOMETHING ABOUT, TRAFFIC
CONGESTION, MOBILITY ISSUES AND
THE LIKE WHEN IT COMES TO THE,
TO THE, TO EMPLOYMENT AND THE
WORKPLACE. OF COURSE, I'M FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, INLAND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, WHERE WE
HAVE NOTHING BUT CONGESTION AND
IMPACT. HOW HOW WOULD THESE DATA
POINTS WORK TO, INFORM US ABOUT
THOSE ISSUES AND POSSIBLE
SOLUTIONS? I WOULD SAY THE MOST
VALUABLE DATA POINT FOR THAT SET
OF ISSUES IS ABOUT THE LOCATION
OF WORK. RIGHT NOW, THE BASE
WAGE FILE REPORTS THAT THE
EMPLOYERS MAIN LOCATION AND ALL
THE WORKERS. THE ONLY
INFORMATION YOU HAVE ABOUT THEIR
LOCATION IS, IS THEIR EMPLOYER'S
HEADQUARTERS, BUT THAT DOESN'T
ALLOW YOU TO SEE IF, FOR
EXAMPLE, AN EMPLOYER IS GREATLY
EXPANDING EMPLOYMENT AT ONE OF
ITS WAREHOUSES, THAT THE CHANGE
IN EMPLOYMENT OF THAT WAREHOUSE
IS WHAT DRIVES LOCAL TRAFFIC
CONGESTION. AND SO BEING ABLE TO
GENERATE LOCALIZED MEASURES OF
EMPLOYMENT GROWTH IN REAL TIME
WOULD BE VERY VALUABLE FOR
UNDERSTANDING WHERE WE'RE LIKELY
TO FACE FUTURE TRAFFIC
CONGESTION, WHERE WE NEED TO
PLAN FOR MORE TRANSIT, OR OTHER
OTHER WAYS OF HELPING WORKERS
GET TO WORK. AND WHEN I TALK
ABOUT OUR TRAFFIC SITUATION DOWN
THERE AND VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
AND THE VARIOUS RESTRICTIONS
THAT WE HAVE ON EXPANDING THE
MODES OF TRANSPORTATION, WE KNOW
WE'RE BUILDING HOUSES OUT IN THE
INLAND PART. I JUST ASSUME
PEOPLE ARE TRAVELING TO JOBS IN
THE COASTAL AREAS, BUT IT MAY OR
MAY NOT BE TRUE. BUT THESE DATA
POINTS WOULD ACTUALLY PINPOINT
WHERE PEOPLE ARE WORKING WHO
LIVE IN PARTICULAR AREAS OF THE
STATE. EXACTLY. SO YOU COULD USE
THESE TO GENERATE POINT TO POINT
COMMUTES. AND THEN FINALLY IN
SOME OF THE MATERIAL THAT WAS IN
THE BINDER, I NOTE, TOPICS SUCH
AS UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AND
PAID FAMILY LEAVE BEING
REFERENCED AS, AS ISSUES THAT
THESE DATA POINTS COULD IMPACT.
AND I'M MAYBE YOU COULD CLARIFY
THAT FOR ME. HOW DOES THAT WORK?
WELL, I'LL JUST GIVE ONE
EXAMPLE. THERE ARE LOTS OF WAYS
THAT ONE COULD USE THIS. BUT ONE
EXAMPLE WOULD BE TO UNDERSTAND
WHETHER WHETHER FOR ALL
CATEGORIES OF WORKERS, ALL
CLASSES OF WORKERS ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS THE BENEFITS ON AN IN AN
EQUITABLE WAY. AND WE CAN DO
THAT RIGHT NOW BY QUARTERLY
EARNINGS TO UNDERSTAND WHETHER
WORKERS WITH WITH HIGHER
QUARTERLY EARNINGS ARE MORE OR
LESS ABLE TO ACCESS THAN WORKERS
WITH LOWER QUARTERLY EARNINGS.
BUT QUARTERLY EARNINGS IS NOT A
GREAT PROXY FOR HOW WELL OFF THE
WORKER IS, HOW SKILLED THE
WORKER IS. HOURLY WAGES WOULD BE
MUCH BETTER FOR THAT. AND SO
UNDERSTANDING THE HOURLY WAGE
DISTRIBUTION OF PEOPLE WHO
RECEIVE BENEFITS UNDER DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS WOULD BE WOULD BE VERY
USEFUL. I, I SEE, VERY
INFORMATIVE. THANK YOU. YES,
MA'AM. THANK YOU. SENATOR ROTH
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS, FOR
INVITING ME TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY ON JOBS AND THE ECONOMY
ARE THE TOP CONCERN FOR
CALIFORNIANS, ACCORDING TO THE
PBS STATEWIDE SURVEY. AS OF
FEBRUARY, I THINK THE LATEST ONE
WAS AND ON TOP OF THAT,
CALIFORNIANS ARE VERY WORRIED
ABOUT ECONOMIC MOBILITY. 71%
BELIEVE THAT THE STATE'S
CHILDREN WILL BE WORSE OFF THAN
THEIR PARENTS FINANCIALLY WHEN
THEY REACH ADULTHOOD. AND I
WOULD ARGUE THERE ARE STRONG
ECONOMIC HEADWINDS TODAY. BUT
ALSO, CALIFORNIA HAS A LOT OF
STRENGTHS TO DRAW ON OUR LARGE,
DIVERSE, INNOVATIVE ECONOMY AND
FOR ME, DEVELOPING THE SKILLS,
THE EDUCATION, THE TRAINING TO
CONNECT CALIFORNIANS TO JOBS OF
THE FUTURE IS CRITICAL IN THIS
REGARD TO GENERATE THE KIND OF
MOBILITY THAT CALIFORNIANS ARE
LOOKING FOR AND BETTER NEAR-TERM
OUTCOMES, IN ADDITION, OUR
SURVEY WORK AT PPIC FINDS THAT
STATE INVESTMENTS IN JOB
TRAINING ARE AMONG THE MOST
POPULAR, WHEN THINKING ABOUT
WHERE GOVERNMENT CAN BE
EFFECTIVE, 81% OF CALIFORNIANS
SAY THEY SUPPORT INCREASED
FUNDING FOR JOB TRAINING
PROGRAMS. THAT'S FROM OUR
NOVEMBER, STATEWIDE SURVEY. AND
THAT VIEW IS SHARED REALLY
ROBUSTLY ACROSS DEMOGRAPHIC
GROUPS, ACROSS REGIONS, ACROSS
THOSE WHO IDENTIFY WITH
DIFFERENT, DIFFERENT, POLITICAL
PARTIES. SO TO SHED LIGHT ON THE
VALUE OF NEW DATA COLLECTED
THROUGH THE BASE WAGE FILE, I
WANTED TO MAKE A FEW POINTS
BASED ON MY EXPERIENCE AS A AS A
RESEARCHER STUDYING THE LABOR
MARKET IN CALIFORNIA. VÀ. AND
I'LL DRAW ON RESEARCH THAT I AND
OTHER COLLEAGUES AT PPIC HAVE
HAVE DONE USING THE BASE WAGE
FILE AS WELL. SO I WANT TO JUST
START WITH REFLECTIONS ON HOW
WORKFORCE PROGRAM EVALUATION
COULD BE COULD BE STRENGTHENED
BY THE DATA ELEMENTS THAT ARE
UNDER DISCUSSION TODAY. IN 2019,
WE PUBLISHED A RIGOROUS
EVALUATION OF CAREER EDUCATION
PROGRAMS, OR CTE PROGRAMS AT
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THIS WAS MADE POSSIBLE UNDER AN
MOU WITH THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
THAT INCLUDED ACCESS TO
INDIVIDUAL LEVEL, DE-IDENTIFIED
STUDENT RECORDS THAT WERE LINKED
TO ELEMENTS OF THE BASE WAGE
FILE. WE USE THIS TO EVALUATE
THE IMPACT OF EARNING A CAREER
EDUCATION CREDENTIAL ON AN
INDIVIDUAL'S EARNINGS, AND WE
FOUND A 20% INCREASE FOR
GRADUATES WITH A CTE ASSOCIATE'S
DEGREE OR LONG OR SHORT TERM
CERTIFICATE. AND THAT'S RELATIVE
TO WHAT THEY WOULD HAVE EARNED
IN ABSENCE OF EARNING THAT
CREDENTIAL. ALL THIS WAS
POSSIBLE TO DO BECAUSE WE HAVE
THE LONG EARNINGS HISTORY OF CTE
STUDENTS, WHICH ARE ON AVERAGE A
BIT OLDER AND HAVE LONG WORK
HISTORIES COMPARED TO THE
AVERAGE COLLEGE STUDENT THAT YOU
MIGHT IMAGINE, WE FOUND, IN
ADDITION, A LOT OF VARIATION
ACROSS PROGRAMS, ACROSS TYPES OF
DEGREES. SO EARNINGS GAINS WERE
HIGHER FOR THE LONGER
CERTIFICATE OR FOR AN
ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE. AND ACROSS
PROGRAMS. SO CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES, I KNOW IT
WILL NOT SURPRISE YOU, HEALTH
HEALTH PROGRAMS BY FAR AND AWAY
GENERATE THE LARGEST EARNINGS
RETURNS FOR GRADUATES. THAT'S
MOSTLY DRIVEN BY REGISTERED
NURSING ASSOCIATE'S DEGREES. WE
ALSO LOOKED AT AND I THINK THIS
MIGHT BE RELEVANT TO YOUR
QUESTIONS AROUND CAREER
PROGRESSION. WE EVALUATED CAREER
EDUCATION PROGRAMS THAT STACK
CREDENTIALS. SO FOR EXAMPLE, IN
THE RENEWABLE ENERGY SPACE, YOU
MIGHT START WITH A CERTIFICATE
THAT YOU CAN GET UNDER A YEAR IN
KIND OF ENERGY FUNDAMENTALS. AND
THEN YOU MIGHT ADVANCE TO THE
NEXT CREDENTIAL, WHICH MIGHT BE
A LONG TERM CERTIFICATE OR AN
ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE IN IN SOLAR
INSTALLATION TECHNOLOGY. AND
THESE ARE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
REALLY BUILT TO BUILD IN THAT
CAREER PROGRESSION, THE KIND OF
MOBILITY THAT WE'RE HOPING THESE
PROGRAMS CAN GENERATE LITERALLY
INTO THE INTO THE PROGRAM. AND
THERE'S A NUMBER OF THEM ACROSS,
ACROSS THE STATE. SO WE WANTED
TO SEE TO WHAT EXTENT ACHIEVING
CREDENTIALS ALONG THESE PATHWAYS
, ACTUALLY WAS REFLECTED IN
EARNINGS AND WE FOUND,
UNFORTUNATELY, NOT A LOT OF
STUDENTS WHO KIND OF START WITH
THE SHORT TERM CREDENTIAL
CONTINUE ON ON THESE PATHWAYS,
WHICH IS ONE ISSUE, BUT THOSE
WHO DO, YOU KNOW, KIND OF STACK
AN ADDITIONAL CREDENTIAL WILL
SEE A MEANINGFUL INCREASE IN
THEIR EARNINGS, AND LAST, IN
THIS WORK, WE WANTED TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE EARNINGS
GAINS MEAN RELATIVE TO KIND OF
ECONOMIC MOBILITY TO LIVING WAGE
THAT YOU'VE REFERRED TO. WHAT WE
DID WAS WE LOOKED AT THE KIND OF
TRAJECTORY FOR STUDENTS WHO
ACHIEVED THESE CAREER EDUCATION
CREDENTIALS RELATIVE TO WHAT I
WOULD CALL AN OBJECTIVE
THRESHOLD OF ECONOMIC NEED. THAT
WE DREW FROM THE PC, PC,
STANFORD, CALIFORNIA POVERTY
MEASURE. SO IT'S AN ESTIMATE OF
ECONOMIC NEED THAT VARIES BY
COUNTY ACCORDING TO VARIATION IN
COST OF LIVING. AND WE USE THAT
TO GENERATE WHAT A MIDDLE INCOME
LEVEL OF EARNINGS WOULD BE FOR
AN INDIVIDUAL. AND WE FOUND THAT
MOST GRADUATES OF CAREER
EDUCATION PROGRAMS, ACHIEVED
THAT MIDDLE INCOME LEVEL OF
EARNINGS WITHIN SIX YEARS OF
GETTING THEIR CREDENTIAL. AGAIN
VARIES A LOT DEPENDING ON THE
TYPE OF CREDENTIAL, THE PROGRAM,
THE LENGTH OF THE CREDENTIAL. SO
THESE INSIGHTS, I BELIEVE, ARE
REALLY POWERFUL AND HELPFUL IN
UNDERSTANDING HOW GRADUATES OF
CAREER EDUCATION PROGRAMS FARE
OVERALL, ECONOMICALLY. BUT THEY
DON'T TELL US HOW WELL THE
PROGRAMS ARE PREPARING STUDENTS
FOR THE CAREERS IN WHICH THEY'VE
TRAINED, AND WHETHER THE
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE EMBEDDED IN
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES ROBUST
CTE OFFERINGS ARE ACTUALLY
MEETING LABOR MARKET NEEDS. SO I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THREE REASONS
WHY THE ENHANCED DATA THAT'S ON
THE TABLE TODAY COULD ADDRESS
THOSE GAPS. SO IF WE KNEW THE
OCCUPATION THAT THESE GRADUATES
OF CAREER EDUCATION PROGRAMS
WERE WORKING IN, WE COULD MUCH
BETTER UNDERSTAND IF THE
EARNINGS TRAJECTORIES THAT WE
SEE REFLECT REAL GAINS DUE TO
THE TRAINING THAT THEY GOT. SO,
AS JESSE MENTIONED, YOU KNOW, IN
SOME CASES WE CAN LOOK AT THE
INDUSTRY AND KNOW. SO IF A
NURSING STUDENT WENT FROM THE
RETAIL SECTOR TO THE HOSPITAL
SECTOR, WE'RE PRETTY SURE THAT
THEY'RE WORKING NOW IN A HEALTH
RELATED FIELD. BUT THEY MAY NOT
BE A REGISTERED NURSE, EVEN
THOUGH THAT'S THEIR CREDENTIAL.
AND INDEED, WE DO SEE SOME
DIFFERENCES IN GAINS, EVEN FOR
THAT KIND OF HIGH RETURN PROGRAM
ACROSS DEMOGRAPHIC GROUPS. AND
IT COULD BE RELATED TO UNDER
PLACEMENT IN THE JOB THAT
THEY'VE TRAINED FOR, IN
ADDITION, THAT STACKABLE
CREDENTIALS EXAMPLE THAT I GAVE
YOU, WHICH WE FIND TO BE A
POWERFUL ILLUSTRATION OF
ECONOMIC MOBILITY, YOU KNOW, THE
BEST THAT WE CAN DO IS LOOK AT
HOW EARNINGS AT THE QUARTERLY
LEVEL JUMP, NOT WHETHER THOSE
ADDITIONAL CERTIFICATES,
ADDITIONAL SKILLS ARE ACTUALLY
HELPING SOMEBODY MOVE INTO A
HIGHER LEVEL OCCUPATION IN IN
TERMS OF WORK LOCATION, YOU
KNOW, I MENTIONED THAT WE LOOKED
AT, YOU KNOW, EARNINGS RELATIVE
TO, YOU KNOW, ARE YOU EARNING
MIDDLE INCOME LEVEL OF WAGES,
THAT WAS DONE BASED ON WHERE YOU
ATTENDED COMMUNITY COLLEGE, NOT
WHERE YOUR ACTUAL WORK IS. SO
THAT'S A LIMITATION OF THE
ANALYSIS. HISTORICALLY IN THIS
CASE, COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
OFTEN WORK AND LIVE NEAR WHERE
THEY ATTEND SCHOOL. ALTHOUGH I
THINK THAT'S AN ASSUMPTION BASED
ON HISTORICAL TRENDS. IT
PROBABLY NEEDS REEVALUATION
BECAUSE WE HAVE MORE ONLINE
SCHOOLING OPPORTUNITIES AND WE
HAVE AN INTENSE NEED SOMETIMES
TO MOVE TO JOB OPPORTUNITY. SO
HAVING THE WORK LOCATION WOULD
REALLY REFINE HOW THE PROGRAMS
ARE RELATED TO HOW THEY ALIGN
WITH REGIONAL LABOR MARKET
NEEDS. AND LASTLY, YOU KNOW,
HAVING HOURLY INFORMATION WOULD
ALLOW US TO BE MORE NUANCED IN
OUR ANALYSIS OF THE RETURNS TO
THESE KIND OF CREDENTIALS. SO WE
SEE EARNINGS INCREASE. WE DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S BECAUSE YOU'RE
WORKING MORE HOURS. AND IN SOME
CASES WE SEE, YOU KNOW, NOT A
LOT OF EARNINGS GROWTH FOR SOME
PROGRAMS. AND THAT COULD BE
BECAUSE YOUR YOUR HOURS ARE
MUTED OR ACTUALLY DECREASED FOR
A VARIETY OF REASONS. SO
ALTOGETHER EITHER IN THE SPACE
OF CAREER EDUCATION, WHICH I
HOPE IS ILLUSTRATING FOR YOU
HOW, HOW THIS COULD WORK IN
OTHER KINDS OF TRAINING
PROGRAMS. YOU KNOW, THESE
ADDITIONAL DATA FIELDS, COULD
ADD A LOT OF VALUE TO
UNDERSTANDING THE LABOR MARKET
AND THE VALUE OF THE PROGRAMS
FOR THE STUDENTS. AND THE
POTENTIAL EMPLOYERS THAT THEY
MAY, MAY GO TO. I WANT TO KIND
OF FINISH ON TWO POINTS. THAT, A
LITTLE BIT MORE BROAD RELATIVE
TO THE POTENTIAL USES FOR THIS
DATA, IN OTHER WAYS. SO FIRST,
YOU KNOW, THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT THE PC IS IN
THE MIDST OF OR HAS EVALUATED
USING THE BASE WAGE DATA. AND I
JUST WANTED TO MENTION THESE TO
YOU IN CASE, IT'S PART OF YOUR
CONSIDERATIONS IN ADVANCING SB
755. SO MY COLLEAGUES AT PC
RECENTLY ANALYZED THE EMPLOYMENT
DYNAMICS FOR CAL FRESH
PARTICIPANTS. SO THIS WAS
RESEARCH CONDUCTED UNDER AN MOU
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES, WHERE AGAIN,
DE-IDENTIFIED INDIVIDUAL RECORDS
WERE LINKED WITH THE BASE WAGE
FILE AND UNDERSTANDING THE KIND
OF EMPLOYMENT, REALITIES OF CAL
FRESH PARTICIPANTS MATTERS FOR
UNDERSTANDING THE NEEDS OF THAT
PROGRAM. WHAT KIND OF CHURN,
THOSE WHO RUN THE PROGRAM MIGHT
EXPECT, IN A LABOR MARKET WHERE
THERE'S A HIGH SHARE OF LOW WAGE
JOBS, THERE'S OFTEN A LOT OF
VOLATILITY AND WORK FOR LOW
INCOME POPULATIONS. THE
ADDITIONAL, ANOTHER TEAM AT EPIC
IS EVALUATING THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS, AGAIN,
USING DE-IDENTIFIED INDIVIDUAL
LEVEL DATA LINKED WITH THE BASE
WAGE FILE. SO IN BOTH OF THESE
CASES, YOU KNOW, ENHANCED DATA
ON THE OCCUPATION IN HOURS AND
LOCATION OF WORK COULD REALLY
PROVIDE FOR A MORE DETAILED
LABOR MARKET ANALYSIS TO INFORM
THE EFFICACY OF THOSE PROGRAMS
THAT RELATE TO KIND OF LABOR
MARKET OUTCOMES FOR CALIFORNIANS
WHO TOUCH THOSE STATE PROGRAMS.
AND FINALLY, JUST GENERALLY, YOU
KNOW, I BELIEVE THESE DATA
ENHANCEMENTS CAN HELP CALIFORNIA
MEET THE LABOR MARKET CHALLENGES
THAT LIE AHEAD, GIVEN THE
TRANSITIONS THAT ARE ON THE
HORIZON FROM CLIMATE CHANGE AND
TRANSITION TO CLEAN ENERGY, TO
FROM AI TO AND AUTOMATION TO
MAJOR DEMOGRAPHIC CHANGES,
INCLUDING THE RETIREMENT OF A
VERY LARGE, BABY BOOMER
GENERATION. OUR WORKFORCE
SYSTEMS ARE GOING TO NEED TO BE
ADAPTABLE AND ACCESSIBLE, AND
WHILE WE DON'T WANT TO BURDEN
EMPLOYERS WITH ADDITIONAL DATA
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS, WE DO
WANT TO ENSURE THAT EMPLOYERS
CAN RELY ON A TRAINED, AVAILABLE
WORKFORCE WHERE THEY CAN
CONFIDENTLY LOCATE IN CALIFORNIA
AND GROW, OTHER STATES AND
NATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS ARE
LOOKING TO ENHANCE THIS DATA. AS
WE'VE TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
TODAY, YOU KNOW, WITH THE AIM OF
STRENGTHENING THE LINK BETWEEN
EDUCATION AND OPPORTUNITY, AND
AT A TIME WHEN CALIFORNIANS ARE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE ECONOMY
, BOTH NOW AND FOR THE FUTURE,
FOR THEIR CHILDREN, I'M REALLY
ENCOURAGED BY THE POTENTIAL TO
STRENGTHEN THE STATE'S ABILITY
TO SHEPHERD SUCCESSFUL
STRATEGIES FOR ECONOMIC GROWTH
AND ECONOMIC WELL-BEING FOR OUR
FAMILIES, OUR BUSINESSES AND OUR
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE
TODAY. THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMENTS, WITH RESPECT TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CTE PROGRAM
EVALUATION, I GATHER THEN AS A
RESULT, AS A RESULT OF THE
EVALUATION, YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
ACTUALLY ESTABLISH THAT
INDIVIDUALS TRAINED WERE WORKING
IN JOBS FOR WHICH THEY WERE
TRAINED. THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
SO YOU HAVE THE SAME YOU HAD THE
SAME LIMITATIONS IN YOUR PICK,
EVALUATION AND STUDY THAT ALL
THE REST OF US HAVE EXACTLY, WE
KNOW WE DON'T KNOW, FOR EXAMPLE,
WHETHER A CNA OR AN LVN THAT
COMES OUT OF A TRAINING PROGRAM
AND REPORTS A WAGE INCREASE,
WHETHER THE WAGE INCREASE IS
BECAUSE THE LVN OR THE CNA TOOK
A JOB AT NORDSTROM'S OR
MCDONALD'S OR SOMETHING ELSE,
FOR EXAMPLE, WE'RE PRETTY SURE
THAT THERE IS A BUMP FROM
GETTING THE CREDENTIAL, BECAUSE
WHAT WE SEE IS A TRAJECTORY OF
EARNINGS THAT IS PRETTY
CONSISTENT AT A, YOU KNOW, A
RATE THAT WE CAN IDENTIFY
STATISTICALLY. AND THEN AFTER A
CREDENTIAL, YOU SEE JUST KIND OF
THE TRAJECTORY CHANGES, IT KIND
OF BUMPS YOU TO A HIGHER LEVEL.
THAT'S IN AN EFFECTIVE,
CREDENTIAL THAT IS EARNED. BUT
WE CAN'T SAY FOR SURE IF IT WAS
EXACTLY THAT CREDENTIAL OR
SOMETHING ELSE ABOUT WHAT
CHANGED IN IN THAT STUDENT'S
TRAJECTORY AT THAT TIME THAT
THEY GOT THEIR DEGREE OR THE
GENERAL LABOR MARKET OR THE
ECONOMY OR SOMETHING WE DID UP
HERE WITH RESPECT TO REQUIRED
WAGES. EXACTLY. ARE THERE HAS
HAS ANYONE BEEN ABLE TO DO A
STUDY OR EVALUATION OF TRAINING
PROGRAMS? RAIMES, FOR EXAMPLE,
EITHER NARROW OR BROAD, TO
ACTUALLY CONNECT THE DOTS AND AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT INDIVIDUALS
TRAINED RECEIVED JOBS IN THE IN
THE AREAS FOR WHICH THEY WERE
TRAINED. WELL I'LL LET JESSE
SPEAK TO THIS TOO, BUT THERE IS
A ROBUST ACADEMIC LITERATURE ON
JOB TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT, FOR
THE MOST PART, I THINK IS FAIR
TO SAY, USES DIFFERENT KINDS OF
DATA THAT'S MORE DETAILED THAT
ACTUALLY EITHER IT'S A, YOU
KNOW, A STUDY THAT IS TRACKING
AT SOMETIMES AT HIGH COST
PARTICIPANTS BEFORE, DURING AND
AFTER. SO WE CAN GATHER A WIDE
RANGE OF INFORMATION ABOUT THEM
WITH WHICH TO KIND OF THEN BACK
OUT THE IMPACT OF A PROGRAM. A
LOT OF THESE EVALUATIONS ARE
DONE, YOU KNOW, WHEN IT'S WHEN
IT'S FEASIBLE, GIVEN DATA OR
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO A,
YOU KNOW, A REMOTE, A CONTROLLED
KIND OF TRIAL OF A PROGRAM. SO
IT'S HARD TO GENERALIZE. IT MAY
BE HARD TO GENERALIZE FROM THOSE
INDIVIDUAL STUDIES, ON KIND OF,
THE IMPACT OF, OF TRAINING
PROGRAMS, FOR INSTANCE, AT WORK
IN CALIFORNIA TODAY, IT APPEARS
TO ME THAT IT ACTUALLY WOULD
DEPEND ON SOMEONE REACHING OUT
AND TOUCHING A PARTICIPANT IN A
PROGRAM, HAVING THE PARTICIPANT
BEING WILLING TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION, AND THEN COLLECTING
THIS VOLUNTARILY SUPPLIED
INFORMATION, AND TRYING TO
CONNECT DOTS, WHICH I GUESS
WOULD CALL INTO QUESTION THE
VALIDITY OF THE STUDY, IN TERMS
OF WHO PARTICIPATES AND WHO
DOESN'T. IS THAT ABOUT RIGHT? I
THINK I THINK THAT'S RIGHT. THE
WHEN THIS IS DONE, IT'S
TYPICALLY DONE AS PART OF LARGE
MULTI-MILLION DOLLAR EVALUATIONS
FUNDED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR, THE US DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR, THAT ARE THAT RELY ON
SURVEYS. THEY THEY SURVEY A
SAMPLE OF PEOPLE, THEY TRY TO
GET PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE AND
THEY FOLLOW UP WITH THEM AFTER
AFTER THE TRAINING. THAT MAKES
IT VERY EXPENSIVE MEANS YOU DO.
YOU ONLY DO IT EVERY 10 OR 15
YEARS. IT ALSO MEANS THAT THE
SAMPLES TEND TO BE FAIRLY SMALL,
WHICH WHICH ONE OF THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT IS THAT
THEY CAN OFTEN EVALUATE A
GENERAL CLASS OF TRAINING
PROGRAMS, BUT THEY CAN'T GET
MUCH TEXTURE INTO PARTICULAR
PROGRAMS OR PARTICULAR
CREDENTIALS THAT PEOPLE MIGHT BE
STUDYING FOR, IT'S JUST
INFEASIBLE TO DO THAT WITH
SURVEYS. I REMEMBER WHEN I WAS
DEALING WITH EDUCATION FINANCE,
I'D ASKED, PARTICULARLY IN THE
HIGHER EDUCATION AREA, CAN'T YOU
TELL ME WHAT YOUR STUDENTS, WHAT
YOUR GRADUATES ARE DOING, AT THE
TWO YEAR POINT, AT THE FIVE YEAR
POINT. AND THE ANSWER WAS NO, WE
HAVE TO. WE'LL SEND A SURVEY OUT
THROUGH OUR ALUMNI ASSOCIATION.
SO TO THOSE STUDENTS WHO'VE
THOUGHT ENOUGH ABOUT THEIR
SCHOOL TO STAY IN CONTACT WITH
THE ALUMNI ASSOCIATION, THEY MAY
OR MAY NOT RESPOND. BUT WE CAN'T
COLLECT DATA WITH ANY DEGREE OF
ACCURACY AND IN DETAIL TO DRAW
CONCLUSIONS AS TO WHAT STUDENTS
ARE DOING, HOW THEY'RE DOING,
AND WHETHER THE JOB THAT THEY
HAVE, ASSUMING THEY HAVE ONE,
MATCHES UP WITH THE DEGREE AND
THE TRAINING PROGRAM THAT WE
PROVIDED IN THE COLLEGE OR
UNIVERSITY IN QUESTION. AND, YOU
KNOW, GIVEN THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT WE PASS THROUGH THE
PIPELINE HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, PICK A FIGURE 2
BILLION, 3 BILLION, 4 BILLION
OVER A PERIOD OF TIME, WE OUGHT
TO HAVE A BETTER DATA COLLECTION
EFFORT AND A BETTER ANALYSIS
SYSTEM GOING ON. SO WE CAN WE
CAN VALIDATE THE TRAINING
PROGRAMS OR NOT BASED ON, HOW
EFFECTIVE THEY ARE IN MEETING
THE NEEDS OF THE PARTICIPANTS.
WILL YOU ALL HAVE BEEN VERY,
VERY, INFORMATIVE. ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS? ON THE PANEL? THANK
YOU ALL FOR COMING AND FOR
PARTICIPATING AND PRESENTING.
EXCELLENT TESTIMONY. THANK YOU.
LET'S SEE IF ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
WANTS TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT.
I DON'T SEE ANYBODY JUMPING UP.
I SEE HEADS NODDING, WHICH IS
NØ. SO I THINK WE'RE GETTING
CLOSE TO CLOSING THE HEARING
OUT. I WANT TO I WANT TO THANK
THE ADMINISTRATION AND GOVERNOR
NEWSOM FOR MAKING ADMINISTRATION
STAFF AVAILABLE TO PARTICIPATE
TODAY IN THE OVERSIGHT HEARING.
AND FRANKLY, FOR AUTHORIZING
THEIR PARTICIPATION IN THE
PREPARATION OF AN EXCELLENT
REPORT ON SENATE BILL 755. I
WANT TO THANK YOU, TOO, FOR
TRAVELING FROM WHEREVER YOU CAME
FROM. TO BE WITH US TODAY WAS
WITH SOME VERY INFORMATIVE
TESTIMONY. AND AGAIN, I WANT TO
THANK THE GENTLEMAN TO MY LEFT,
DAN ROUNDS, AND MY STAFF,
KEARNEY KING. AND I SEE MY CHIEF
OF STAFF IN THE IN THE HEARING
ROOM, GILBERT MARTINEZ, FOR
THEIR HELP AND PUSHING THROUGH
SENATE BILL 755 AND FOR PUTTING
TOGETHER THE INFORMATION
NECESSARY FOR THIS OVERSIGHT
HEARING. MORE TO COME, I HOPE. I
SEE, A BILL NEXT YEAR FROM MY
VANTAGE POINT, WHEREVER THAT IS,
DIRECTING ON SOME IN SOME WAY,
ON SOME BASIS, THE EMPLOYER
COMMUNITY TO START OVER TIME
SUBMITTING DATA AND AUTHORIZING
THE APPROPRIATE APPROPRIATION TO
THE VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES TO PUT THIS 755 IN
PLAY. STAY TUNED. THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH FOR ATTENDING. HAVE A
GREAT DAY. THE HEARING OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED.